three two one
let's go
get out take it out
now
oh
yes
foreign
better
okay
um
is
so
um
there there's
there's
this would be stalemate if i
don't do this okay sure sure
xqcl
but i can play queen c8 this is a ridiculous
move where i still stayed defending my rook your
queen now is under attack and your rook is also
under attack and you can't defend everything oh
wait what if i did this oh
you're trying to get here
yeah how do you handle that threat unfortunately
there's this with check oh there's check
check i forgot the queen can go that way thank you
that's my queen no oh i blundered i'm blending bad
oh he gave me it back thank you so much
okay okay he let me undo oh thank you
okay okay
no that's my queen yes
i've got one idea only one idea that'll be so [
__ ] good please don't mess this up all i need
to do is move the point up here he'll be trapped
yes he's trapped please tell me is please please
please please please please has you got
anything can you do anything can you do anything
yes taking d5 to d6 takes d5 takes e6 so put
the d5 on e6 and you will see that magic happens
yes i've never wow that was a mind that's like a
glitch was that but i'm terrible at this game i'm
really so bad i'm so bad that was so embarrassing
in so many ways he wants a rematch get out of here
holy sh come here dude
oh my god he is so whole oh my god
oh i had checkmate i got so scared wait wait
no don't stop everybody stop
shut up shut up shut up stop
stop oh oh one second i just got
disconnected give me one second chance
it's our chance to eat everything
it's actually working go back
sorry oh janet chad come see me in my office
it's fine okay we can recover from this you were i
saw clips of you talking trash non-stop before the
game okay and then also says the one that streams
like my streamer says when i was sitting in my
chat watching my tactics sent me a clip someone
sent me a clip okay that's not sitting in your
stream no you were in my streams specifically
more than one hour okay we have to use in the
chat you stream sniped my tactics i use shadowy i
for starters i use chaturino and secondly slicker
if you want to watch me play chess in my channel
twitch tv slash name you're welcome to do so maybe
you'll learn a thing or two well okay let me
tell you so let me tell you something listen
let me tell you these everyone this guy is a
joke let me tell you right now a simple joke
why think what you're doing think nim okay go back
to being a dj my friend because you don't know who
you're messing around with well i mean i think
more than that for me it's not it's not so much
about guessing it's the fact that oh oh oh my gosh
here comes the oh like this here comes the owl oh
my god listen name if you're watching do you
guys swear is this piggy three are you allowed
to swear in this interview um i mean preferably
not but you don't really nim you are a pile of
rubbish you are gonna lose me if you're watching
this you're gonna lose you're gonna absolutely get
destroyed trust me and we are live we're joined
by ludwig and boxbox ludwig do you want to ask
the question you you just did before we were
on yeah alex um my questions why did you
yeah from weaponized sex toys to chess drama seems
like the natural progression there i think i think
everyone would really be surprised if you take
nothing else away from today i think the thing
to take away is just how versatile sex toys can
truly be like there's so much more to them than
they get credit taking an object like a flashlight
a rubber vagina and seeing it in a different way
as long as you make sure that the opponent's
king has squares or if it doesn't you're
checking it that's the way to go for it here you
go it's the world's smallest violin playing just
i told
i have to join an interview okay see you later
see ya peter thank you hello oh sorry not yet
son of a son of a
no you just have to move your piece unless
you can take so then he's going to grab me
god damn it
i'm gonna waste time here this is what
you get for this mate i'm gonna waste time
two minutes i waste my time
let me blast some two bags
ignores what i suggested which is completely
fine if this is what he prepared oh oh you
think he prepared this he likes gambits oh wow oh
wow so ludwig decides to play the latvian gambit
um now we'll see right away if ludwig did some
preparation here yeah let's let's take a listen
into his stream to see what he's saying yeah
sure he said he doesn't have time to teach me he
said ludwig okay uh teach a lot about wow i could
teach a lot of uh uh well uh what what's xqc up to
apparently my viewer count the latvian gambit
advice so his one piece of advice being gambit
but now what do i do now what am i supposed to
do hikaru this is not what i told you at all um
the process here because when you bring out
the bishop like this uh it can become very
vulnerable right away so i'm not sure that i
like the like the variational approach here
no please don't and it's too soon it's too
soon hikaru we didn't even reach a climax
like this isn't really defending
anything except this piece she she
uh he could take this but i could take this um
i'ma just do this wait what what was that the
move wait i can't move his piece what was
i gonna do what was it gonna do oh my god
what was it gonna do what was my move
oh no it was my move what was my move
wait was i thinking about doing this because
i can't oh i'm gonna go like this oh no she's
doing that box box was playing his master
promo not he's not quite challenger but he's
he's on his way um i'm not either right now you
know leaves a struggle sometimes but anyway so i i
i beat him i hard carry against him in the game he
needed to win for his master promo as a as a good
friend you would think oh like i would go easy on
him like maybe you know give him a chance no no
he needs to earn that and just like he needs
to earn this chess pog champs championship
and he wants to meet me in the next round or
whatever like you know albert zang bring it on
but i destroyed him in the master promo and i'm
gonna fudging destroy him in the chess match
i hope you spend 50 hours studying my openings
and analyzing my games and get coached by hikaru
alexander danny and magnus carlson because no
matter what you do box box i will destroy you
you're going to be one box smashed into a little
cube and i'm gonna checkmate that ass so easily so
you know when i said it'd be fun to see a
checkmate in four earlier i was i was joking
it was i it wasn't real we're listening to moist
critical right now daniel naraditsky is a prophet
he said immediately that xqc will likely go with
the scotch open and he did so i had the counter
play and he immediately blundered well that's
got to be a world record my is throbbing okay
every game that it makes that far i won't
go that far okay i won't go that far listen
hearthstone stick to hearthstone okay listen
you stick to playing mage or whatever the
other champions are that's you're just 2d
andy that's what you are foreskin i mean um
forsen okay starcraft is quiet the
complicated again well i mean it's
stuck i feel like i'll play starcraft are you
50 years old are you the tomorrow's age no
oh my god look at that okay i actually have to oh
my god it's on the board it's on the board of god
oh my god
she only saw that it was a
chat she didn't see the queen
she's a queen i am a freaking genius
why'd you give your bishop for free though come
on little you had 500 gifted subs on the line
you cannot be living life with that kind of risk
alex alex here's a little thing that i'm going
to pass on to from one streamer to another it's
called throwing for content you got to make it a
little more exciting all right throwing a hanging
bishop have everybody in suspense for a moment
my end game's phenomenal you know why
i pick up the vorkshki's endgame book
okay now i can't read a [ __ ] word of
this because it's all in chess notation
it makes no sense but i own it and this
alone has been a 300 point up for me
um have you been like sleeping next to
it trying to get some you know awesome
every night i no longer own a pillow i just
sleep on dvorsky's book fourth edition all right
so we're going to be watching this chess match
here guys um it's between moist critical and xqc
well i guess that's the end of the chess
match between moist critical and xqc
another riveting bout between those two
now
yes
hey oh
uh
one two three
oh my god there's more oh my god this is insane
yeah baby that's what i've been waiting
for that's what it's all about magic time
oh
and we are back with the final day of pogchamps
three presented by grip six hey caro we did it
another amazing pogchamps event is about to be
in the books how excited are you for championship
sunday uh really excited i think both matchups
today are going to be really really close i think
this match between sardosh and rayne wilson two
of the early favorites in the championship bracket
um i think it's anyone's game and then
there's a match between nico and michelle care
uh also i think it's very hard to have predicted
that that either of them would have reached the
final i'm in the consolation brackets so all the
players who are here they deserve to be be here
they've played very well throughout and it's going
to be really really exciting we're going to have a
fun day here as we bring it to a close regardless
of who wins let's remind everybody who's already
been here for a while i hope you enjoyed that
season one highlights video to remind you of where
it all began but let's bring everybody's attention
to the format and remind them of what's in store
as zaccaro said we're in the bracket stage it's
single elimination which always hurts at this
stage it's not as fun almost in some way zacaro
as the early group stage because we know that
we might be watching someone's last match in every
moment right because you know it's win or go home
but it's still a blast and obviously yesterday
and the day before we had matches go to tiebreaker
so will it happen again today if it does it's
only five minutes with a zero second increment
uh to uh to decide who who moves on or in
this case actually wins their particular
bracket uh and then of course the uh as we
said it's two brackets as a car already noted
we have consolation and championship the
prizes that are up for the individual
players are what you see before you it's a
hundred thousand dollars in guaranteed cash
that goes directly to the players for them
to spend however they want i know players
like rayne wilson intend for all of what
they earn here probably to go to charity
but i know that for a lot of streamers too this is
a really big payday it's a huge chess tournament
and a lot of money on the line and speaking of
what goes to charity just.com came into this
event with the intent to spend a hundred thousand
dollars on top of the 100 000 prize fund and
so today announcing right now we are doubling
the match of the community which means you the
community have already raised more than 75 000 and
if you help us reach that fifty thousand dollar
mark it will mean a hundred thousand dollars cash
out of chess.com's pocket so we're hopeful to get
there but no matter what happens on sunday we know
the community you've already done such an amazing
job you've been super generous but we're hoping
to spend all hundred thousand dollars of our money
and we hope that you help us get there by reaching
that fifty thousand dollar mark all right hicaro
let's talk a little bit about these particular
match-ups nico versus michelle carrey as you said
neither player maybe was expected to get there but
maybe in hindsight we should have seen it coming
either way it's definitely two players with very
opposite styles yeah certainly i think one of the
things that emerged from pogchamps too is we had
hafu who ended up winning the whole event she won
the champions bracket and ever since she started
grinding every day there have been like people
who have been comparing um some of the players
who have been trying to study like her and i
think two of the players in the finals on both
sides championship and in the constellation and
sardosh and michelle kari have kind of sort
of done the mini hafu or the full hawfu
um especially in saradosh's case where it seems
like he's playing chess 23 hours a day um but in
terms of michelle she also has been grinding every
day doing just a few hours and so her progress
i think from the group stage winning winning two
matches i think she had to play both her quarters
and semis on the same day against mr beast and
pokeyman and now playing here in the final today
um she's been doing an amazing job so uh both
of them are looking good i think i'm actually
going to go out on a limb and predict that that
michelle is going to win and i think sardosh is
going to win as well okay well there you go and i
you know i'll echo what you said that michelle um
okay a lot of players have improved a ton so
i hope anyone listening doesn't take that the
wrong way but i think an argument can be made that
michelle might have improved the most of anyone as
far as where she came kind of just learning the
rules of the game to where she is now so that's
been just inspiring to see and of course we can't
wait to see uh whatever that uh video kind of
documentary looks like as far as her journey and
what her experience was in pogchamps and with the
chess community um and yeah i don't think you're
uh you're crazy to be predicting sardosh at all
um obviously i've been working with rayne for
on and off for a few years now and certainly he
came into this event to have fun and it's gotten
more serious for him as he's proven to himself
maybe he has a chance but but i think
sardo's i mean i i can kind of explain
i can kind of explain why i think sardosh is a
clear favorite because i was thinking about this
last night and um i think when i look at sardosh
in the games that he lost the games they lost to
benjamin in the game that he also lost ludwig
neither of those players really made many major
mistakes there were mistakes made by benji and
ludwig in those games but they played a pretty
good game from start to finish at five like
and when i think about reigns progress he's
played very very well but when he hasn't gotten
a big advantage at the very start of the game
he has not put together a complete game so
that's that's the the single biggest reason i
think sardosh is very likely to win is i feel like
rain at critical moments has made some mistakes um
in some of the some of the matchups i think
against sardos making mistakes of the nature
that he's made in some of these earlier matches
will be will be insurmountable totally fair and
also i think you and i have talked a lot about
it for some reason you and i have had several uh
sardosh matches he just seems to be best in fast
time control right and so another reason why it's
kind of hard to pick against the the hard-working
frenchman is because of just how well he's carried
himself in those most critical moments and by the
way unity just rolling in right now thank you so
much again remember we are doubling our previous
double i don't know how to say that but no matter
what you see on the screen it's it's double more
than that so if we reach 50 000 it will mean a
hundred thousand dollars from chess.com so thank
you so much throughout the day if we get there
also before we take our first break and come back
with the starts of the matches thank you again
to our sponsors uh guyaki is supporting dog
champs with their donation and with cases
of your favorite regenerative yerba mate they're
celebrating 25 years and they're sharing the love
to prove it of course we really appreciate their
support and any subscriber to the chess channel
can win multiple cases of gaia ki or yerba mate
if you spam the emote right now you know the drill
you've subscribed for a while some of you are
going to be winning your romantic cases can't
wait for it and thank you so much already for the
community support don't go anywhere when hikaro
and i come back it's championship sunday it's nico
versus michelle correa consolation bracket finals
with pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6
returns the regeneration of the planet
is integrated into our business model purchases
of guayaqui yerba mate support stewardship of
the south american atlantic rainforest and the
self-sufficiency of indigenous communities these
purchases advance a carbon-balanced renewable
energy economy and provide meaningful employment
for the formerly incarcerated guayaqui's sales
also fuel communities and activists driving the
regenerative movement meanwhile your enjoyment
of yerba mate reconnects you with the vitality of
life when we come to life we care about one
another and stand together to create a better
future what's your username bishop
i've say clg c-o-g so who wants to play
oh you're a little too low bro anybody
above 900 so around 900 who's 900.
yo any 900ers hey chess tv what's
up we're currently doing sub battles
we're trying to find somebody who is
900 rated to play in the sub battle
any 900 we just need one 900 rated dude just one
one sub what's your use today you're
here why can't i not start your game
you have to go to live chess
buddy go to live chess right now
i know where they last i know where they last but
it's fine because we lost in sub battles today
we're going to win in lcs right
guys that's how karma works
because we lost in sub battles at
cog cog's gonna pop the [ __ ] up
in lscs today right right
you're in live chess is your username correct
we're we're gonna win tonight we're
gonna win tonight don't even sweat it
don't even sweat it we are go who
are we playing tonight actually
oh we're playing dignitas ah they're only
the second place team in the lcs right now
yeah this is gonna be a win for sure hey frick
crazy thank you for the two one no but honestly
cog has been getting first bloods 11 out of
11 games like we will win tonight we will okay
pinky promise we're gonna win tonight right chat
don't even worry don't even worry okay we also i
mean this is actually over but maybe maybe if we
win the next two games i can ask alireza if he
wants to play me in a game and we'll see how
that goes no no we're going to win tonight
gootax we're going to win i think we have
a very good chance to win not only in this
game actually it doesn't really matter if
we win anymore here but i want cog to win
cog can win tonight okay okay we got this
uh
and welcome back to pogchamps 3 presented by
grip6 it's championship sunday and before the
championship matchup the consolation bracket
occurs we have both niko and michelle carrey
here to talk a little bit about the charities
they chose um with all the support raining in
here we can't wait to hear from these ladies to
tell us a little bit about why they chose their
charity what it means to them and so nico over to
you first the charity you chose is unicef tell us
why you chose that charity and um any anything
that it means to you and and all that stuff um
so i was very in a hurry to pick a charity and i
was just there's like so many causes i care about
but i feel like above like all of them
i think one of something i really do
care about is like the humanitarian
work and i feel like unicef provides
all that across like the world and i was like
well that blankets like everywhere you know not
just specific a specific region so that's kind
of like what i chose you know that everyone has
uh at least like the necessities and that's
really important to me that makes a lot of
sense michelle you chose face africa uh tell us
a little bit about that charity and what your
connection is to them and what you what you like
about what what the work the work is that they do
yeah absolutely so face africa is a really amazing
organization that builds water wells in africa for
communities that do not have running water most of
the water fetching responsibilities usually fall
on women in the communities and because women
end up spending so much time walking back and
forth from the water sources which can oftentimes
be several miles away from their home it prohibits
them from spending as much time in school or
advancing and other educational aspects so they
do a lot of amazing work and when they install the
well they actually do a full community project to
educate the community on how to upkeep the well
and sort of build an economy around it and also
do a lot of sexual health education for the women
in the men and i just think it's really amazing
i've worked with them a few times and i would
love to contribute again to their cause especially
because they're doing so much wonderful relief
there or covid as well wow amazing just made it
impossible for me and hicario to root for either
of you both those charities sound awesome hey cara
which i'm just kidding pretend that they're
not here which charity are you rooting for
mean i i don't have one to pick but i will
say that i haven't spent i spent some time um
in in africa i was inside i've been in south
africa i've been i was in libya many years ago
so um so i i have seen some of the
some of the everyday struggles um
in africa and i i think it's it's a
great cause so i'll just leave it there
but both are great thank you so much obviously
unicef in the humanitarian work as you said
we never they all all need more support
for all those types of causes and of course
michelle you broke down what face africa does it's
incredible and we hope that both of them receive
the most money possible and uh we appreciate all
that uh all that they do so for you ladies we'll
wish you both good luck we know you're here to
now go win the chess tournament and and uh do
everything you can so carl and i will see you
on the other side win or lose and uh have fun
thank you thank you thank you all right well
now they're going to get set for their games
that was fun and really interesting hearing more
about face africa specifically unicef is a larger
um more globally known i think charity hikaru
and some people not obviously it's an amazing
charity and as nico said does does great work
for just general humanitarian efforts but
really cool to hear michelle talk about face
africa um and yeah i mean again i think anything
i think anything for um anything for charity is
is always good though to stress again um i think
i think all the charities that the participants
chose them they're all amazing i don't think
anyone chose the same same charity which in and
of itself is also pretty amazing uh when you think
about it they all chose uh individual charities
that's 16 different charities um yep and it's
it's it's great i think it's very important to
give back to the people who are less fortunate
indeed indeed well apparently we're going to
take one more break as the ladies now go from
our interviews to logging into to the live chef
server so thank you so much to scott colliver
uh ryan's connor zorded bobby baron there were
multiple other 100 donations too and many more
so thank you so much to everybody um every every
dime counts and we will be back in just a moment
with the consolation final getting underway figure
out tactics off stream um people i've met so many
of you guys through this experience and i'm really
really grateful for that i mean obviously getting
to learn chess is the game and have a greater
appreciation for that has been amazing um
but i think what's been even better is just
sort of growing our little community um our
our community has grown uh over double in the past
month which is really really special and exciting
so thank you so much for everyone uh for for
who's new here who may have found me through this
or has been here forever i i really
really appreciate it um i wasn't ex
expecting this to happen when i started streaming
and specifically when i started streaming chess
i wasn't sure if anyone would
watch and it turns out everybody
is enjoying chess so today's going to be a really
great match i'm super super excited had some
training with anna rudolph yesterday queen anna
um the most wholesome chess coach on planet earth
i would venture to say um and so this is going
to be really great uh nico moves very quickly
and she has a very unique opening so i've been
doing a little bit of studying of that um however
castlemania that's all i gotta say castlemania
if you know you know it's a
way of life not a strategy
okay i guess there's nothing to
do but just sit here and wait
also just shout out to nico who has played so
like thousands of chess games and has grown
as a player so much um reflected by her
incredible rating increase over this entire
preparation and tournament bracket it's been
really amazing to watch so much to learn from you
detachable octopus friday was my birthday and
i took half a day off work to watch pog champs
and watching you win two matches was the
perfect birthday present oh happy birthday
can't wait for this match you're ready i hope so
whoo 11 1 1 stream thank you so much for the prime
anna cranling's community is cheering you
on good luck michelle caples michelle i wish
you a fantastic match let's make it happen i'm
with you oh thank you guys for the hype train
someone wants to know what castlemania
means just have to experience it
just going over the move order in my head
we're gonna be playing black pieces first guys
so hopefully everything we learned
with anna will come into play i feel
like after all of that studying yesterday
i don't even remember the london oh my god
albert levin you got this michelle
let's do this thank you albert
shout out to albert for playing a game
with me this morning to help me prepare
mkkkm michelle carrey castlemania let's
get hyped guys let's get hyped i'm
ready
i'm bj minton the founder of grip six when i
was 14 my very first job was a janitor at an
elementary school and i saved up my money and
one of the first things i bought was a wooden
chessboard from the mall i love chess chess
is challenging chess is thinking ahead it's
planning it's problem solving it's very similar
in manufacturing because in manufacturing
it's nothing but problems but problems are what
stimulate your brain problems are the things
that actually push you into creating new things
new technology better products things like that
at grip6 we make belts wallets and
socks we guarantee them for life
and just like chest they'll be around forever
rip six has loved being involved with pogchamps
3. we we all know that and they're super excited
to see who wears the championship belt i'm i'm
excited i don't know what's going to happen with
that i can't wait to see whether that building
makes it on stream and cameras across the world
but either way we want to give you one more
reminder to go to go.just.com grip6 make sure
you use the pogchamps 20 code before it expires
it expires after today so if you've been watching
you want to get yourself a belt some socks
whatever it is go to pogchamps sorry go.just.com
grip6 or grip6.compogchamps use the promo code and
get 20 off all right decaro here we go so i asked
a question while you were while you were talking
which was you have the belt personally right i do
it's right here indeed i i already said that if
ludwig won i was gonna refuse to send it to him
but he was the only person i wouldn't send it to
um but is there only one for the champions bracket
or is there only the only one for the championship
bracket that's a good point i think next time
around no matter what the prize is we should
have one for the consolation bracket as well
agreed agree absolutely population us um yeah
i i came fully decked out in grip six today i
don't want to show my belt i know you're not into
that he carried me flashing my belt on camera
but i will come on get flexible damn come on
dan there you go right there grip six sucks okay
we're all we're all ready grip six here
we go time for the games let's do this
for the win yep game one all right so nico nico
said to me and you off camera i i was talking to
her about the lesson we did uh meaning melissa
mia nico did and she said she wished she had
just admitted to me then that she was married
to the birds um but she's been playing tons of
other openings besides the birds here so she's
she she just didn't want to play the opening
i taught her she could have just told me that
right exactly so i think she's been varying it
she played like the english yesterday against
tubble i think she played uh was it d4 or g
she had some other setup as well so she was
really mixing it up quite a bit yeah and jokes
aside everyone i did do lessons with both nico
and michelle so i'm not gonna i'm not gonna claim
to be a mother torn as anna rudolph feels when
she has two students playing i only did one but
definitely worked with both of these ladies
and they have both performed incredibly well
so it's exciting to see and look at michelle
playing principal chess striking at the center
exactly so far so good looks like a french
defense um i like the way that both players
have uh have opened so far i think again um one
thing that's very unusual oh right on cue i was
worried about the d6 oh it's right back yeah it's
right there again no no yeah but the thing is you
know the thing with niko is i i don't know what
it is exactly but unlike any other competitor
in the field she just moves instantly like she
just does not think she just moves instantly and
um and for better or worse i think especially in
blitz that's really really good but she does miss
things because i think she gets set on one move
or one idea and does not consider alternatives
well said and yeah it has been a
storyline for sure and of course it's
if nico was ever in future chess events maybe
maybe the coaching would be even more focused
on that because she's done so many things so
well right carl it's just that right when she's
it's it's when she's had these opportunities
you just want her to take a breath for a second
and consider it so it was several moves in a
row she had this work idea right exactly yeah
so i mean one thing that i would say is i think
michelle if michelle can keep her nerves together
and use her time and not sort of get flustered
by niko's instant moving i think uh she will
she'll do very well that's really the big key i
think actually for anyone who played against nico
um was being able to control the tempo and
not get pan not panic and get flustered when
one should make these moves in like two to three
seconds and um and so i think that's really going
to be the important thing michelle can keep
her nerves and use use uh use like five ten
seconds every move um and try to think about
ideas or even 30 seconds on occasional boost
she's in good shape but if she gets flustered
and starts trying to match the pace of nico
um then i think bad things are going to happen
no i agree with you because if it becomes a
battle of blitz intuition or just who's faster
nico is nico is the nakamura in the consolation
bracket we'll say that she's faster than her
opponents i don't know if you've heard of it
my kids showed him a tick tock video of him
the other day it's pretty fast um yeah so yeah
no she really is and we saw yesterday i mean i
know you were watching with me and it was i mean
nico won because of her speed on the clock right
it came down to the tiebreaker and she and she
flagged tubo on time right right exactly but again
also in the first game she blundered when she
tried to make her instant move and in the second
game as well she made it and she made an incident
which was blunder but tubo actually hung his queen
because i think he started getting panicked by the
instant moves as well and um and so i think that's
really the critical thing no matter who is playing
as nico's remember there are 10 minutes on the
clock now there's a certain cutoff i would say
if you're playing an opponent who moves instantly
um i would say when you start getting down like
four if you get around four minutes when you have
to start moving instantly but or like using two to
three seconds but until you get to that point
using five to ten seconds every move is not a
bad idea right and we see michelle used a minute
and one second for the chess.com time logs there
on that move rookie eight which was a good move
um now she's gonna play a little faster by the
way there have been multiple north of three-digit
donations we've already raised and there's another
one mikey tko that means we've raised 90 000
together remember chess.com is doubling the match
so 30 thousand from the community is now 60 000
from chess.com we hope to spend all one hundred
thousand one hundred thousand dollars um all right
rookie 890 c3 is a great move by nico hickar look
at her taking advantage of the undefended bishop
on d6 right so nico is playing a great opening so
far um i think for michelle i like knight e5
that's a very good move very good move by uh
by michelle and see this is the problem nico she's
like she she has this inability to use her time so
she immediately takes night and doesn't look for
alternatives and that's i think the biggest uh
the biggest issue um in in terms of in terms
of niko's is she a lot of her intuition is very
good but she just is incapable of stopping and
thinking for like 10 seconds at certain moments
where she did i think already she could have
won this game at least two or three times yep
and she has more time than she started with
again five seconds increment is on the clock
everyone which means nico nico is moving on
average faster than five seconds per move
that's ikaro's point and if she could slow down
we had the fork earlier and this pawn is just
hanging here if she sees it she could win the
pawn it would be a huge advantage right exactly
that's a good move too though i like rookie six
of course e5 is a very good move by nico as well
so um yeah let's see let's see what happens
here um michelle does need to move her bishop
here however she does not move her bishop here
um bad things will happen yeah we got a hanging
bishop here one thing i'll say about nico is even
though she plays super fast and all the you know
whatever call it criticism or advice we're just
trying to be encouraging for her to slow down
is true but one thing she does record if you look
at her for the most part she tends to focus on her
opponent's clock like she tends to be putting in
effort and she's kind of stone-faced which i think
allows her to make up for for some of the time she
doesn't take not everybody is as focused on their
opponent's clock i.e some of our screaming
streamers talking to you ludwig and tubbo
just kidding love you guys but seriously right
nico is super focused on her opponent's clock
right agreed but you also do need to be super
focused on the board as well and that is something
that ludwig definitely does uh wait what shall
we say right anyways so um she takes now he's not
going to win the pawn um obviously it is the hard
balance of like a content creator and a competitor
right so teasing ludwig and tubo aside the
truth is we know that they're there to entertain
you entertain when you play bullet and blitz it is
a hard balance right to make sure you're working
hard on the x's and o's and and being fun for
your chat ludwig's not here to entertain lotto
was out to win did you not see how heartbroken
it was after a lot after he lost to sardosh the
dude was like taking lessons and with hess off
stream for one hour every single day no longer
well yeah you got the colors wrong danny of course
it's your fault if ludwig plays with white in the
first game and wins he probably doesn't lose the
second game with black which is what should have
happened so yes of course it's your fault and
ludwig is 100 right i thought you were going to
be on my side on that that was a all right anyway
i'm a content creator i'm a streamer i don't know
anything about chess you're the guy who plays
chess i know my fault all right moving on well
we've got bishop f1 played by nico not not a bad
move either i guess she has this bishop c4 in mind
um yeah i think i think so um now
the question here is for michelle
is what will she do will she move her rook
move the bishop um it's a it's a difficult
situation here because her rook on aid
and the bishop on theater are not really
well developed here um so she has to find a way to
uh to get the bishop from the rook into the game
let's listen into her for the first time and
see what her ideas are to solve those problems
d5 was good not talking too much
look at rook c1 by nico bishop c4
oh my god oh man she's fast and strong
yeah this is a great great play by her
you know is you can tell how nervous she is man
yeah i mean i think um i think this is a big issue
here is that again nico what she's doing is um her
moves like she might miss wins but her moves are
still good they might not be the best ones that
finish the game but she is still making moves that
that make a lot of sense and if she plays like
this and doesn't say blender or rook or a queen um
it's going to be very tough to to match her it's
going to be very very hard i like queen d7 though
now we'll see whether nico i would say there's
almost there's almost no chance she'll play
bishop h3 because she's clear she should be
tunneling on bishop c4 right but of course
now i see that watch use 10 seconds to play
bishop h3 exactly the first time in the game um
let's see she is slowing down like she recognizes
she got a lead on the clock and now she
what did she play oh she played a3 strange move
subtle uh oh uh oh oh here comes a diagonal uh-oh
that could spell disaster for nico everyone
in fact at the very least she recognizes
how dangerous it was and is willing to
compromise her king position to not get
hated but still that that's a move you're
going to wish you could have back right
right but but f3 is a great move by nico
yeah let's see what happens that's the mating idea
i don't know whether you're drinking any you're
ramate and your mug hiccaro but i've got a mug
here too you want to show everybody your
mug let's compare bugs but the problem is
my my mug the the water is no longer hot so you
can't see me anymore i already left the building
oh man you had the car mug earlier
i'm sorry i missed it no no i mean
what i mean danny is it's a mug where there's
a picture on it but if the wa you know when
you when the water is boiling it shows up when
the water cools off it disappears so i already
left it so i just left the building that sounds
like witchcraft and wizardry to me i don't know
yeah yeah it's a magic mug base i'm gonna
call i'm gonna call magic on that um all right
f3 was played but look okay so the time advantage
that nico is getting here yeah so mess it's it's
it's yeah it's a big time advantage for her the
one thing i would say about the position though
is that for michelle it's actually quite easy to
play i feel like in terms of what she's trying to
do the bishops are pretty pretty ideally placed
the queen is well played so i think if she sees
the idea to bring the other rook to the center her
moves are pretty straightforward i would say here
yeah agreed and and like you said
even though bishop h3 is on the board
there we go she blunders it
she sees the taxi idea the problem is the queen
guards the pawn on f3 now i think niko we'll see
if niko sees rook takes bishop or will she play
bishop c4 i think one of those two moves will
be played here i just don't know which one um oh
okay she goes bishop e2 that's a huge opportunity
that's that's also a terrible move and i'll tell
the reason i think it's a terrible move is because
now it stops queen f3 so there's no there's almost
no way that um that michelle can blunder it kind
of or right she can just blunder it he did blow
to her bishop on the second a second to go around
but nico isn't looking for it it seems
like even though niko's playing fast
she seems to be in a defensive state of mind too
the move she's been playing for a while bishop f1
right as i say that she plays an
aggressive vote right which is a good move
and now i think that means she sees that um oh wow
okay yeah and now unfortunately after they trade
now i think nico is almost certainly gonna spot
uh rook takes bishop oh wow because now it's just
very yeah i mean now now it's now it's impossible
not to see because you see where your pieces are
so the only chance for michelle here is to push
her d-pawn that's the only chance she has um now
will she see it i i kind of think she should see
it but again i think the problem for michelle is
also i suspect she did not to be she did not
expect to be in this position and so i think
she's also very nervous as well so you're right i
think she's going to see d3 indeed she has but but
it's more the body language you can tell
just how frustrated she is that she's
oh oh that's a free rook oh my gosh but it's
still anyone's game right oh my god my god
ah i agree okay
there's no way she takes the rook right i don't
think she'll see it oh she still doesn't see it
okay see that this is very dangerous for both
players though because the idea of rook g2 is
looming here yep like rook g2 too and if michelle
doesn't play king of one she's in big trouble
uh you mean if nico doesn't play king of one all
right niko yeah yeah but still i mean richie two
is very scary here but michelle's not looking
at it if michelle does not see richie too then
i think nico probably is going to win this game
yeah i agree um especially because if again if she
doesn't see rookie 2 nico's position is becoming
the easy one to play she has a clear plan push the
b pawn because michelle he doesn't see if rookie
two doesn't have a clear plan right exactly yeah
okay rookie two not the best move
but not the worst movie either
yeah right now yeah now now she has to
play i i mean rook a3 maybe it's still
it's kind of hinging on on the edge here okay king
of seven now don't go rook eight and hang the rook
that would be very bad it's so funny because
it's the retreating move right you and hess
talk about that a lot as far as retreating moves
being missed that's why michelle miss bishop
takes rook and she might miss it again if niko
plays for hey right backwards bishop captures i
think are the hardest it's the hardest capture to
see or even just general backwards bishop moves
um because it's not really natural and in the way
like knights you can just it's generally much more
it's much more clearer it's a lot a lot more
straightforward okay e6 is a great move here
um but yeah i think i think michelle is
just panicked now e7 and it's game over
and and it's even worse because the pawn on b5
accidentally guards c6 so there's there's not
even a way to stop you yeah yeah no totally yeah
oh look at nico coming in moving fast but getting
it done yeah no totally and i think um it's it's
looking looks like niko's gonna win the game here
it would take a miracle of
astronomical proportions
um yeah and you talk about there's not even a way
like in different levels of just understanding
to like mess this up for white there's no
way to stop this and there's no way to not
just play a bunch of checks after
that if you're niko right exactly
so yeah i can't think you make the queen the
king moves and now queen e5 and rook h7 should
just be pretty easy the only trick is richie
two rick takes g3 that's the only way here
um for uh for michelle to try and stay in the game
wow what a finish that would be by the
way if that happens if she sees richie too
and nico blunders yeah and then king h1 rookie
iii is the one mate that exists the only mate
that exists here um but i think g2 king
f1 she will see and then it's game over
amazing just to show what hiccaro said there
how it's so funny because if michelle had played
richie too i think there was a chance that white
would have played king h1 which is literally yeah
i mean to be fair it's 50 50 right you could go
either way there yeah it's 50 50. anything could
have happened so it's it's obviously ended the way
it was kind of supposed to and that and then you
know nico seemed to have played better and she
won but that would have been a wild finish yeah
okay um we have game one in the books for our
consolation bracket championship uh that means
michelle is now in win or go home territory
sending it to a tie break against nico would
be amazing but she's got her work out for
her so don't go anywhere we will be right
back with game two of the consolation bracket
final when podcast three presented by grip six
returns
all right
definitely not my best game but
that was really hard good job nico
oh man
on to the next game
did i miss
oh damn man
all right i mean honestly
guys i feel like i peaked on
friday and then i just have no idea how
to play chess anymore after all of that
all right now just wait for the next game
okay i believe in myself i believe in
myself
thank you for your support guys
and let's do a shout out to our merch store if
you enjoyed pogchamps 3 presented by grip6 this
is your chance to get some gear at chefs.com's
merch store commemorative of what an amazing
event this was it's pretty cool i've got a
shirt and a hoodie they're comfy and cozy
you want to go to chess.com merch store and pick
yourself up some pogchamp swag go ahead and do it
uh maybe your last chance to do so if it all
runs out it is it is limited in quantity speaking
of last chance this might be your last chance to
play our pog champs bots not all of them will stay
on the chest.com server once the event is over so
i know a lot of people have really been enjoying
beating ludwig i'm not gonna lie i've enjoyed all
the tweets coming at me every time you do it but
um jokes aside this is your chance if you want to
play the pogchamps and bots before they disappear
and okay this is our this is your last
chance if you're michelle carrey hicaro to uh
to make to make all your dreams come true here
what has she got to do in game two as white
to make it happen yeah so here in game two i
think for michelle she needs to keep it um very
tight sort of be calm just stick to her opening
and play relatively quickly for the first like
10 moves and then just get herself into the game
i think it's really really important to do that
yeah so kind of like don't lose your head sort of
sort of thing right exactly still have a chance so
all right well uh game two is about to start
we are over thirty thousand dollars from the
community which means we're over ninety
thousand dollars total as that is double
matched by chess.com that's awesome news let's uh
let's get over 100 000 soon here we go game two
right so here we go so d4 played on
move one okay so i think michelle
she's been playing the london right yep
and she's been all london all right exactly
yeah okay so nego plays g6 okay now the one
thing i would say is with the king's indian
it's a little bit harder sort of to play
play the setup and and it's very dangerous because
also we can go both ways where there's going to
be a knight bd7 e5 e4 a fork in the center
again so i think this could get very spicy
right away i wonder if nico got some tips on
playing we know she fian kettles anyway so
maybe not um but i'll be curious to see what
happens in the post-match interviews because
the the king's indian setup as you said is
kind of perfect to play against the london
right exactly yeah i think it's a great opening
setup um like knight d7 rookie at e5 i think dog
dog won a game against uh was it sex row in
pog champs so i don't remember which one um
but now nico goes d5 and i really don't like
d5 here yeah us a wasted tempo start and
michelle plays queen c2 you often
if you can take a queen's pawn
and your opponent can't take
back with one of these pawns
you should do it and ruin the position
so yeah wow c5 nico getting aggressive
yeah i like the actually you know the thing that
i will say about nico though is um it seems like
it's only situations where there's like one or two
moves where opponent has a chance to really get
something but immediately when they when they sort
of don't seize on the opportunity the game gets
very complicated and they're forced to think or
think i should say think and use up a lot of time
right um and i think already it's gonna be hard
for michelle here with all the all the pressure
in the in the middle of the board with all
these pawns here do not um not sort of think
for a couple of minutes and potentially go wrong
because it's just it's not a common structure
either out of london yes normally in london
you want something very smooth with the pawns
on c3 d4 e3 but the pawn's on c4 here so um it's
going to be interesting to see what what she does
yeah and this is when you have these types
of pawn traits i mean even super experienced
strong players can miscalculate make the wrong
decision be left with an isolated pawn so this
is going to be super tricky i do like knight
d2 even though you know black is still okay
as well she's completing development um right
but nico speaking of which does the same thing
developing her night exactly yeah yeah so
i mean i think i think in general terms um
nico's got a great position i mean the problem
for michelle and this is why i also sometimes
don't like the london opening is if your
opponent does not play a traditional pawn
d5 pawn e6 setup the ideas are not as clear-cut
or straightforward like here's the bishop on f4
what is it really threatening it's not threatening
anything on this diagonal the bishop on d3 as well
is not threatening down towards the king on on g8
here because they're a bunch of pawns in the ways
so the ideas are completely different i think it's
very hard to play play if you're not expecting it
i agree and you and i inadvertently end up not
necessarily london bashing but we agree so much
on those conceptually especially as coaches
that the problem with the system is if they
get it great but if not a lot of the pieces
are not ideal for things you would normally
principles you would normally want them focused
on and and here this is better for nico because
you're either going to win the dark square bishop
or i don't think she's going to miss this fork
when two knights can go there so i think
nico's going to get an advantage yet again
yeah and this one actually is is significantly
worse in terms of the texture because the black
king is so safe here that white doesn't really
but i mean to credit michelle finds bishop e4
which is actually a great move uh because the
only weaknesses black has here are on the queen
side that's it nothing else um so it's very
very bishop b4 is a great move by michelle
yeah agreed i've been healed i've been a great
move now you'd love to see michelle save this
bishop if she thinks about that although i mean
obviously taking is natural as well um yeah it's a
tough position tough position here even moves like
bringing the rooks to the center would be good
yeah so i mean it's very uh yeah it's very
it's it's a bad position it's i mean
it's a tough position to play for
white here i mean i think bishop takes
knight in e4 is maybe an idea although
yeah it's just it's a tough position to play
because there's just black's king is so safe here
you have no pieces towards where the black king
is though i think nico she finds a couple of good
moves here she uses a little bit of time and plays
a couple of good moves i think she's very likely
gonna gonna win the match right here so now knight
takes us good um after pawn takes knight i think
knight a5 is the best fight for nico she connects
puts two and two together because in an earl in
their first game in pog champs three she played
against sardosh and she found a 1985 idea with
the bishop on b7 i don't know if it hit a queen
on c4 or what it did exactly but she definitely
found an idea to play knight a5 opening up the
diagonal for the bishop on b7 i remember that
was day one and we had the call on that she she
did find the idea and remember she drew that game
versus the second game versus sardocian and sardo
of course strongest players in the event um right
i take set four was a great move now this is
troubling for michelle the fact that she's taking
time here yeah it ultimately
decides to take the knight first
it's an understandable decision though even
though it's probably going to lose the pawn
it's it's a good decision um overall the again the
problem here though when you look at the position
black has no weaknesses there's only the bishop
on c6 and the pawn on c5 nothing else in the
black position is weak at all so the fact that
niko already won the first game she's up on the
clock it's just very hard to come up with ideas
to um to attack the black position the king is
safe with those four pawns queen side like i
said only one weakness pawn on c5 bishop on c6
if nico for example trades the bishop for the
night and takes the pawn in the center she has
no weaknesses at all and i think it's going
to be very very hard for michelle to come back
yeah you keep you keep coming back to it and now
i realize i want to add to it because what carl
was saying about the king not being weak is so
huge because especially for newer players when
you're when you're in a position that's hard to
blunder that goes a long way and it's really hard
for nico to mess this up with her king being so
safe that's kind of what you're alluding to right
yeah so it's just one of these situations
where it's very very hard to play
shout out to fruit snack with the 200 donation
huge aspiring insomniac first of all aren't we all
a hundred dollar donation and then atlas
192 with 100 bucks thank you so much
all right rook ca what a move by nico by the way
wow yeah i mean a great move bishop takes knight
was maybe a little bit better but again for
nico i think the most important thing is just
don't blunder any pieces if you don't blunder a
bishop here um like i said i think the position
is gonna gonna simplify and the bishop on g7 is
gonna be better than night now one thing that
i actually did not like was there were there
were a couple of people who really tried to
reinforce this notion um for for some of the
some of the students that were teaching that
bishops are better than the knights and um you
know bishops can be better than knights when um
when it's more simplified and bishops have
open diagonals but in general terms i think
for players who are new to the game um bishops
and knights are about equal they are generally
equal it's only at more advanced levels that in
some cases um bishops are stronger than knights so
uh for example like this position the bishop
is better than the knights but you shouldn't
always think about that it just depends on sort
of the piece placement and the open diagonals here
yeah well said it but i i agree i think it's where
advanced players sometimes it creeps in because at
advanced levels we do talk about bishops being
better than the night but it takes a while right
and the knight has so many other dynamic tricks
to it it's harder to spot tactics with knights
especially beginner levels so i agree although as
you just said right now where is this pony going
where's this night going yeah it's night going i
was going to say right now who's the pawn uh-oh
what's happening if nico sees g2 is actually
bishop cheese is actually a blunder because
you could try oh i was just testing you you passed
barely f plus but i mean as long as nico doesn't
blunder here though she's just up a pawn and again
look at the knight the knight on d2 it doesn't
have any great squares and this this game unlike
the first one has been picture perfect um by
nico i would say i mean okay she played d5 that's
the only move d6 to d5 that's the only move that
i think i could criticize at all in this entire
game so far yeah only move that i could criticize
no that's high praise and you're not you're not
kidding i know she has played this is a other
than d65 this is a master level game here by black
yeah absolutely wow this has been been great well
michelle also down three minutes so it's going to
take a lot for her to keep this consolation and
her hog champs dreams alive mm-hmm yeah it's going
to take some time oh no oh no oh no ally oh my god
oh man
i do love how oh my god expression on her
face i know i said that yesterday with levi
she didn't smile until the match was over
literally it was expression oh my god yeah
oh man poor michelle but
also very well played by nico
yeah i mean this has been uh i mean again what
to say nico made one move that at maybe above i
would say maybe 1800 level probably it's a bad
move but below that it's negligible and every
other move except for that has been perfect just
really really nothing and nothing i can say and
she is going to be i think the deserving winner
um in the consolation bracket here in pogchamps 3.
yeah i mean wow i think when we knew it was a
clash of styles yesterday i think levy and i
were leaning michelle would be getting the upper
hand in those styles and even this morning when
you and i were talking about it felt like michelle
but but then you know push came to shove nico has
has really brought her a game
in these last couple matches
yeah i mean i think it's just honestly it's the
fact that she moves fast but even even when she
makes mistakes generally speaking they are major
mistakes if she doesn't hang a queen like she
did against rubius or um or against uh uh tubbo
other than those like glaring mistakes all all
of our other moves in these games have been pretty
good like no no no real errors or inaccuracies so
yeah um i think at the end of the day when
you play like that andrew really fast your
opponent they start feeling the pressure on the
clock too and i think that's played a huge role
in terms of her uh win at winning winning this
uh winning this winning the consolation bracket
b takes a5 queen takes a5 just playing fast
solid chess now she's threatening to win
the night he's also threatening
queen d5 for the record which
be a double attack but we'll
see how michelle handles this
yeah this is just brutal just fall apart
with one move and um if nico plays rick d
dude she's just playing a fantastic game right now
this is you can't even be upset if you're michelle
you just tip your hat what a yeah actually you
know i think in some ways that's actually the
best kind of loss you can have is when your
opponent literally does nothing wrong because
that is just like okay they just played really
well and that's just life um but yeah what to
say just just brutal brutal brutal you're totally
right and we've talked about that a lot the ones
that really haunt you are the ones you know you
were winning the games where your opponent just
kicks your ass you're like well good stuff right
right yeah just come back try to be better but
that's that's how it goes like you just can't
you can't really be that mad about it wow yeah
rook d8 michelle is down to three minutes and
down to her perhaps final moments in pogchamps
three dinner by grip six welcome everyone to the
big show yeah yeah this has been uh pretty pretty
incredible
eat it up yeah yeah not not much to say
will you go heat up your mug so
you can prove to me the magic
um yeah i can go heat up more water
give me one second that'd be sweet
sorry guys i want i believe
in magic and i want to see it
shout out to all of our subscribers as
well and again the community support
we're over 93 000 total between us
all right all right so what happened uh
nothing nico's just cleaning up and uh
yeah this is just i mean just rough
let's talk a little bit about how
the cleanest way is for niko to convert
here because i think that makes these
final moments instructional for the viewers
so if you were coach hikaru here making sure
your students always win when they're winning
what's the fastest way for black to win this
between d5 and bishop c6 i was going to say is
the cleanest way to win um if she plays off six
is there a mindset you have when you're up
this much material should even be just if
you don't see queen d5 just do whatever
you can to trade or what would be yeah
you could also try to trade you could also
try to trade off pizzas um but yeah well now
yeah that would be
she sees that we're just we're walking out
oh my god we're walking yeah yeah here's nico
blowing through the final game here
absolutely crazy mrs mate though
wow you know what's funny there higaro because i
believe she just played queen takes d1 with the
right converting mindset she's like well i'm
just going to trade everything because i'm up
so much she didn't do it was seeing mate she
just did it to get the pieces off right yeah
yeah so i mean i i don't see any way for
michelle to come back here um yeah so uh
now i don't think she'll see on poisson here
probably she'll just push e3 yeah and that's
just yeah game over well thank you dark
dark sapient there were 250 bucks awesome
okay wait a second even stalemate
stephen can't save michelle
right exactly yeah yeah stanley
does not help here that's true
and i don't think i don't think nico's
stalemating yeah yeah very unlikely
multiple ways for mate and one choose your flavor
oh yeah well that's almost there but now yeah
yeah yeah okay [ __ ] mate nico still has not
smiled she takes a calm drink of her juice i
don't know what's in it but uh get me some of
what she's drinking because that was a grand
master level game right exactly yeah i feel like
you know one of those commercials whether like
like someone does something amazing at the bar
and you go i'll have what he's having that's
how i feel right now i'll have what she's having
with what nico just did congratulations to nico
you know hey carl to start the event and
share a little more behind the scenes you
you push for nico to get an invite and you
said how much you felt that she deserved it
because she was streaming chess long
ago and we knew that she would love and
and and probably be a good performer in the event
and here you go she won the consolation bracket
pretty awesome stuff yeah i mean as i think i
said before um long before chess blew up she
actually did play some chess on stream i think it
was 20 it was like late 2019 like october november
um so she was playing chess before it blew up and
uh she really enjoyed the game even back then so
i think it shows um her experience definitely
played played a big role in terms of winning the
consolation bracket yep well and of course we'll
have them for interviews so don't go anywhere
michelle carey also deserves a huge round of
applause so when we return nico and michelle join
us for their final thoughts on their pogchamps 3
presented by grip 6 tournament we'll be right back
i don't know if you guys can hear
it though no my neighbors aren't
dogs they just have a very loud dog
yeah nico won let's go ale oro for nico
okay wait
um i played that i guess i just have to
take yeah yeah i'm gonna watch the finals on
stream
i was so scared for a moment okay oh somebody
made me dab what the heck and another hand heart
okay dude my bullet rating is so low right now
i can't believe i tilted 100 points last night
hey fady how's it going
oh this opening is terrible what am i
doing but it's fine we'll make it work
okay so let's go in here play that
also i promise you guys i'm not sad
today i just don't have any makeup on
every time i don't have makeup on i get asked
a million times if i'm sad i'm not sad i just
don't look great i promise you it's fine
here is that i'm gonna go here and
here i mean it's a losing position but
it's also bullet so
maybe my opponent will be a little bit less bright
why am i down so much time though okay
here here
hmm lame
nico what exactly is in that
juice and can i have some
it is actually a whole foods mandarin
juice i don't know it's sweeter than
regular orange juice so is that what was
drinking too is it is it what is it is it
i think he's just drinking black coffee oh okay
nico seriously what what a day here you showed
up and you know there was a lot of talk coming
in about the different styles between you and
michelle you're one of the fastest players in
the event albeit at times we've talked about it
maybe sometimes people feel you play too fast
right michelle has been has been more methodical
and had this you know she's obviously worked super
hard with her approach to learn and try to master
the game during the event but you just came out
you played fast you played well what what is going
on with nico today and and uh what can you say
um so honestly i was actually really nervous
when i um was was gonna play against michelle
today because i actually lost her when we were
uh playing some practice games with the botezes
so i was all like like she she probably like
is gonna crush me today like blah blah blah
and luckily like i i was just like i think
i played a little slower than i normally did
today because i was uh you guys told me that
she played very methodically so i was very i
was actually very nervous the whole time i was
playing up against her because she seemed like
she was really thinking a lot of her moves through
and um not gonna lie like a lot of her moves were
very tedious like they were very like oh my god i
can't believe she moved there and you know so um i
don't know i was just very i was just very focused
today because i was very nervous and last night i
was losing every chess game that i was playing
on stream so it was that didn't help either
michelle i know this didn't maybe end the way you
wanted but i hope you don't mind me saying i don't
think it makes your pog champs debut any less
incredible as far as where you came over the last
few weeks and what you what you did was inspiring
to watch and i can't wait to be inspired by
whatever video comes out of it but take us through
what's going through your head like we said i know
i know this wasn't the ending you you maybe wanted
but um how are you feeling right now and what
are your what are your final thoughts oh my god
nico was so amazing it was so crazy i feel like
i spent so many hours trying to figure out how to
attack the bird opening yesterday because that's
what it seemed to be played and then she comes out
with something completely different today and i
was like what am i even doing i got i finished my
opening and i feel like i looked up and i was like
this is not what i was expecting right now and
it was so it was so smart it was so wonderful
and it's just it's like so inspiring to see how
how much you've grown and and and just to be
clear like i i may have won one game but nico won
the enti like every other game we played together
it was it was one lucky game so niko's been
totally working hard and it's really inspiring
and amazing and as you guys said yesterday nico
was streaming chess before it was cool to stream
chess so i think it's just only fitting that
queen nico takes her throne go for it nico
michelle thanks so much yeah i i really i really
couldn't um come up with because i haven't been
able to take other lessons with other people and
um i was just really actually nervous on top of
that because i just couldn't i didn't know what
anyone was playing and i felt like everyone know
knew i was playing birds opening because that's
the only thing i just knew at the time and i i
felt like i needed to find a way to juke like my
opponent so like i try to open up differently so
so i'm glad i'm happy that worked but you were
very much a very great opponent thanks michelle
i appreciate those nice words yeah of course
and i think it's just even more inspiring that
you've you were literally like moving around the
country you changed apartments you had a literal
like out power outage for several days and you
still showed up so composed and and played so
wonderfully and i think it's just so inspiring so
i'm just sweating a little bit just a little bit
picard do you think if nico can
switch from bad openings and when
do you think i have a chance to switch
from bad openings and win chess games
maybe maybe one day danny but nico also has one
other thing you don't have which is that she knows
how to make moves very quickly with confidence
and that's not something that you possess
you're you're right uh hikari any other
thoughts we have for our two players here
what's that i said you have any other questions
for our players here not really i mean i just
want to say like for michelle it was amazing
to see your progression from someone who at
the very start of the event i think you would only
learn the basic rules and then just grinding and
playing every day and you did win two-year
matches here in the consolation bracket so
i thought it was a great performance then for
nico um i mean even after coming very close uh
in the group stage uh just to win i think win
all your matches you won two of them in in um
in the blitz games as well just amazing amazing
nerves and amazing chess and you just played
really well throughout so very very well deserved
victory thank you well and again we we thank both
of you just for being a part of the event and of
course for choosing the charities you did both
face africa for michelle and unicef for nico uh
and again um they're both they're both gonna get
get a check because of your ladies performance
here right you made it all the way to the end and
um just again thank you so much for for being a
part of it congratulations nico and michelle can't
wait to see how the how the story turns out thank
you so much thanks guys bye thank you michelle
wow what a fitting ending there that was a a wild
uh wild ride he car not what i saw coming but
in the end niko's experience her intuition right
you know some nerves from michelle uh and also
again the fact that nico played something
that michelle was maybe not prepared for
you know sometimes when you're prepared for
something and then your opponent plays different
it's not what they did they did differently was
that great but it also hurts you psychologically
and i feel like the way michelle talked about
that made me feel like she was really thrown off
more psychologically than she should have been
yeah definitely i think especially when you see
an opponent play the same opening it throws you
off that being said um i feel on one hand perhaps
maybe on a psychological level um she should have
been a little bit more prepared for something
different because niko really did go outside the
box against tubbo uh she did not play traditional
birds openings in either game um so it seems
like she already was starting to branch out
i agree and and in hindsight looking at it from
yesterday you're right she was already mixing it
up and um that should have maybe been a clue and
either way i think it's just a good lesson i mean
any as a chess player as any kind of competing
athlete you got to be ready for or everyone has
a plan until you get punched right and i think
sometimes when your opponent does something
different it's about gathering yourself mentally
even more than it is with the x's and o's and um
shout out to nico for throwing michelle off and
taking hope i mean i mean she deserved to win it's
just that for sure she played she played the best
shots today so very very well deserved well we we
have a championship bracket coming up but before
we do another shout out to a gaia ki or yerba mate
they are celebrating 25 years you know it get your
emotes out spam it subscribe if you got some prime
throw it our way it's free anyway it doesn't cost
you anything and now you might win a whole bunch
of cases of yerba mate because of it so celebrate
25 years of everyone's favorite regenerative
beverage with us by spamming your emotes and don't
go anywhere hey carl when i preview and then dive
in to the championship of pogchamps 3
presented by grip 6 in just a few minutes
this bishop is really annoying
maybe i can just like go for the
king like maybe you just won't notice
this is fine this is not fine
you can take that or you can just play this too
wow what a genius
okay i think you noticed
yeah i think he noticed oops
i thought i could farm the dude
but he actually wasn't that bad
um okay i kind of screwed up my castle i screwed
up my pawn structure so now that i already have
it screwed up why not screw it up even more ah
let's just go here he's gonna play this or not
i mean it's a very scuffed rouser it
could be worse honestly face just gift
to the tier one sub tonight thank you
for the gift what's up thank you okay um
why am i not just winning today
okay so if i go
here he has to play that then i can go
here i mean he just retreats his rook i
this is real bad i don't like this
okay oh thank you newport mad
for the pizza the tier ones
and michelle still reacted so well she has
there reacted so well and it was a tough
defensive position but you got your pieces out
lady and then nico 2 made a mistake um in that
one moment she only made that one blunder which
was also crazy to see that the previous matches
had more mistakes in today's final nico was super
focused and she barely made blunders there was one
or two moments when she went wrong in every other
moment she was spotting the the opportunities she
had so it was rough in that sense that it it
felt like nico was really very sharp today
and the psychological side too um was a tough one
especially when the first game is decided in one's
favor and then you need to make a comeback and
michelle just wanted to play the potus gambit for
the raid we got from the butter's life channel no
i'm i'm gonna stop those bad jokes because this is
this is this is always difficult i i've been
there i've done that many times when i feel
really awful about my own chest because i know
that i could have done better and it's not
about not trying hard enough it's so many factors
when it comes to competitive chess sometimes the
stars align and everything is working amazing and
other times you feel like nothing is working and
even grandmasters who play all the time they their
life is to compete at professional level even
grandmasters sometimes i talk to one of them um
a polish grandmaster who won a tournament that i
played he won the tournament and he was asked what
did he do differently to the previous tournament
where he came like bottom last so imagine someone
who's a grandmaster 2700 his name is radoslav
voitersex is one of the top players of poland he
he's winning the tournament where i'm talking to
him and when i'm listening to this interview
as well and he's asked what's the difference
what what did he do differently to this event
that he has just won to the previous tournament
where he came like bottom last or he did very
poorly and he said he had no idea he didn't know
what made the difference because he had the
same routine same knowledge same preparation
and one tournament turned out really poorly
and the other one he ended up winning within
a short span of time the two tournaments
one after the other and then grandmaster
and as the consolation bracket champion is crowned
queen nico as michelle said retakes her throne we
get we get set for who's gonna who's gonna take
the belt home between rayne wilson and sardo
shikara we pulled up a couple of their big wins
that got them into this championship match just
for you and i to take a quick look at and for the
community to get your thoughts on the different
players strengths and weaknesses so i chose this
one right here in acara where obviously this game
got crazy but sardocia's feel for the middle game
and where to put his pieces seems maybe maybe at a
higher level than anyone else in the event and
he started the plan with rook h4 doubling the
rooks in 95. take us through this game and take
us through your thoughts on just what makes sardo
such a good player well before we get to that
danny you said you wanted to see some magic so i
thought i would show you some action the magic
yes okay so so how does that work heat turns
colors different i don't know i mean i because
twitch is owned by owned by jeff and amazon i just
went to amazon.com and they have these mugs where
you can get an image that's put on it and yeah if
you have hot water it comes on you'll see like
a picture or writing or whatever and then if
it's cold water then there's nothing on it so
i'm not a scientist or anything like that but
i do believe in science and they come up with some
amazing things if this were salem you and i would
be having a serious talk as we move toward the
uh you know the fire pit that's what i'm going
to say that this is this sounds like tom fullery
to me all right so rookie played by sardosh but
your thoughts on just uh the frenchman and all
that he does well right so i thought the way
starters played this game was really really good
um i think in open positions he excels in terms
of the basic concepts of basic ideas like doubling
the rooks here was really good he played 95 after
that um the one thing that i that i think that is
worth noting in this game now it got a lot closer
than it should have even even though stardust won
um was that once he was ahead by the exchange he
tried too hard to tunnel on this idea of pushing
the pawn to f3 now right i'm not sure what the
reasoning behind that was if it's just like he
he learned something less and it was like he
thought he had to go f3 g4 for whatever reason
um the thing that was really important was that
in this position uh he didn't really need to do
that he could have just he could have just gone
for g4 right away here for example tried to open
up the position so it feels like when he gets to
open fishing he has the aggressive ideas he's
very good but when he needs to come with like a
two or three step plan he sometimes can tunnel
on the wrong idea and get into trouble and um
that's the drawback and that's why i was going to
say that when he played against the games he lost
like ludwig the second game and the game against
benji officially they were or the match against
benji fishy they were all positions that were very
close there were no open files it was very much
about maneuvering i guess ludwig ludwig's game
there was really one open file um but nonetheless
they were very closed positions and i think that
that makes a big difference so starter seems like
the more open the position is the more aggressive
he can be the better he does and it makes sense
to win this match rain needs to get positions
like he had against benji uh sort of the sh
this uh slav schlechter opening where it's very
closed um or things where he gets very clear-cut
piece development because the game's against benji
that he won yesterday for example it seemed like
the piece place was pretty straightforward
he had a basic idea and he went with it um
so i think for rayne he's just got to um he's got
to get positions where he knows the structure of
the pawns and he has a piece placement where he
knows where like the knights and the bishops go
great breakdown it almost seems like you said so
after after sardosh played super well here maybe
his own obsession with getting an open position
is what had him obsessed with all the f3 stuff
instead of realizing hey you want material you
can make trades here you could do other simpler
plans even like g4 and like you said rain rain had
a good kind of delivered that heavyweight punch in
the first game i like how levi said it where he
got this good french but the truth is other than
the straightforward french in that in that second
game he was clawing his way back versus benji
and and um i wonder if this match might come down
to who has the mindset that works better when it
doesn't go their way right because we know that
if both players do the things that they're good at
maybe you know maybe they can run away with it
but i want to see who handles the first punch
right who gets punched and doesn't just fall
apart it'll be interesting to see i mean
to me i think it's pretty clear-cut i've said it
before and i'll say it again i think if sardosh
keeps his nerves under control i think he's
has very good chances to win the biggest single
weakness sardoch has that when he gets low on time
or he gets a little bit uncomfortable the position
that he can panic somewhat um also on top of that
um unlike most of the other players it feels like
sardos has the entire french community behind
him rooting for him and i think that also has
a lot of pressure like someone like rayne uh
certainly the the entire country of the united
states on twitch is not is not here like watching
him and rooting for him so it's it's definitely
a little bit different pretty much just fans of
the office or you know people who don't you know
have a lot to do honestly no you're right in fact
i wonder sometimes if that obviously it plays
into your emotions when you've got a million fans
behind you but it might also play into his nerves
right so it'll be interesting to see well yeah i
mean it's like you know what what is this saying
if i if i have one million fans i'm one of them
or something i forget how it goes but but anyway
uh here we go right on cue yeah so um so so as
i was saying like sardo's if you watch when he
does his normal streams he might have two
three thousand i've noticed during podcamps
he's getting up to like 25 30 30 000 viewers so
it really does feel like everyone's coming out
and um and supporting him yep oh man well we are
gonna have uh quite quite the battle here we're
also gonna be joined by the players similarly to
how we were with nico and michelle for them to
talk a little bit about the charities they chose
so can't wait to hear from them on that don't go
anywhere we're gonna take our last break before
being joined by the players for the the charity
interviews and then the games will begin blog
champs will be presented by grip 6 when we return
i myself am trying to learn the piano but i'm
super beginner i'm a super beginner at piano
i wonder if he's he's also really good at
the piano i feel like sardo she's the type of
person that gets really good at
everything he does because he said
that he gets obsessed he gets obsessed with
things that he likes and then he just gets
good at them because he's obsessed oh levi is
playing we can be stalking levy in the meantime
i don't really speak french so i'm just gonna mute
in the meantime until the games begin oh that's me
uh we are following by the way hello charles.com
we have been watching the match between nico and
michelle because i've been working with both
ladies with michelle more closely because
then as nico explained it on previous shows she
had other issues to sort out such as no power
no clean water no food having to move to another
state all those life issues basic human needs
that i'm i'm happy to hear that nico is now in
in a better place and that she has all those
normal conditions that we take for granted when
when nico had to face that kind of challenge right
in the midst of the tournament that meant that she
couldn't take any coaching sessions for the past
two weeks and i'm so proud of both of them nico
played extremely sharp and well today but michelle
has been doing really well in the previous
matches against mr beast and i guess pokey
and the fact that she has started this as a
challenge a month or so ago for her serious
challenge accepted it's it's crazy to to see
that it really is possible to go from zero to
hero i've just been showing her youtube channel
because she has done so many amazing challenges
but most of them she said are physical challenges
she is a former cyclist michelle and her challenge
accepted features things like training to
be an fbi agent a firefighter a lifeguard
all sorts of crazy difficult physical challenges
but this was the first mental challenge and she
has come so far she made it to the finals she
made it to the finals against participants
that oftentimes had more experience than her and
this has been a fascinating match i i know that
as i said i know that michelle will be frustrated
not about the result but that she will feel
like she could have done better because we all
feel bad when we don't play our best chess and
and michelle knows to play the nose that she
knows when you know that you know that you know
that you could have done better that's the
frustrating part i think that's that's what
makes one upset more rather than the result
it's more about just the fact that you try
your best but you don't feel like you're actually
doing your best and that's what i was trying to
describe earlier that chess is such a mysterious
game in that sense that sometimes it really feels
like everything is smooth and easy and the stars
align and other days you are like what am i doing
and you're really trying your best both days but
somehow they don't seem to be the same person the
same level of chess and your knowledge is the
same your preparation is the same your routine
is the same and you don't perform the same way
that's how it goes sometimes so thank you so much
for the two months in advance we are following
um this potential pogchamps four participants
from gotham chess here with the black pieces
a very very promising participant for a future
edition of pogchamps here he's trying to get one
of these pawns his king middle made it all the way
to h3 attacking g3 but the white king is guarding
it bishop to g4 is his threat check and picking
up the knight but that knight could come here and
give a check push the king back will we see that
knight coming here makes sense because that puts
pressure on this pawn and blocks the passport
this makes perfect sense too i think they oh ooh
repetition of moves the king comes here now so
that the bishop when the bishop goes back then
the pawn would fall bishop g4 ain't a good move
here bishop to c6 putting pressure on the e4
pawn as well i am predicting a very brave draw
for this game and that's that's my very very
brave call here zero thank you so much for the
16 gifted subs i think it's 16 because of our sub
goal for real we're gonna hit 2000 which is kind
of like my bullet chest rating i'm terrible at
bullet chess and levy constantly makes fun of it
i really want to be playing in boxing's for come
on we we we can get there with my bullet skills
boxing's for i certainly should
be considered i certainly should
just like i did not try to lose
my queen in that first game
well we are we are live here with some it's been
fun playful banter off camera but we're live now
to everyone and rayne wilson and sardoche we're
here to talk a little bit about the charities
you guys chose and and let the fans know more
about uh what their donations will be going
towards so sorry let's start with you you chose
secure secure popular if i if i did that right
and it's a foundation that helps education
for kids but talk a little bit about
what it does and what that organization means to
you and why you chose it uh they do a lot actually
they are not simply focused on people are still
doing your stuff but right now the code situation
puts a student in a deep trouble like
some don't have enough money to actually
pay their studies they can't even pay their
their bill for their house uh they have to work
on the side to actually uh survive
and it's very hard to actually be so
uh so isolated uh so it helps people with
monetize people with uh food it has people
uh having uh somewhere to live to live and and
they they help people uh just uh keeping them on
their mental sane uh because it's really hard
to support the situation as a student in france
right now sorry for my french from my english
don't be sorry at all man that's awesome and um
and it seems like an amazing organization uh rain
i know that uh your your you and your wife founded
this your particular charity uh laday haiti and
um you talked a little bit about it earlier but
tell the world a little more about it and um
and all the things you guys are doing down there
um thank you thanks danny uh sardosh really nice
to meet you was just chatting and saying hi and
uh listen you know i want to thank everyone for
their donations i mean i think the chess community
has been really generous and you never think like
oh these pimply weirdo nerds would be generous but
um really have been and supporting hikaru some of
his charity stuff's been great chess.com has been
a great supporter of you know raising money for
non-profits so lee day haiti is an organization
i started with my wife in rural haiti and we
do uh education arts education and literacy for
at-risk adolescent girls way out in remote haiti
i mean really far out there we're working with 800
girls in about 11 locations and we have a mobile
computer lab where you teach reading and writing
we do scholarships and uh do health care provide
food and um it's a really awesome organization and
i'm really grateful to to chess.com for letting
me be part of this and and i mean i've already
raised a little bit and uh hopefully raised some
more and uh uh thanks so much and so make sure
you guys are watching make sure you're giving
give big you guys because there chess.com is
going to match whatever you guys put in yeah
and now we're matching double for anyone who
maybe had just tuned in that means collectively
together we have already raised more than 98 000
and it's been an awesome day so far so let's keep
going let's get over that six figure mark soon and
uh it sounds amazing sounds like we need to get
some chess chess memberships too in the hands of
the day haiti as well rain so we'll talk about
this some chess kid memberships too that sounds
incredible stuff thank you both for choosing the
organizations you did what were you going to say
first we need to get them uh electricity
and then internet and then chess.com members
obviously priorities just right above right
above you know some some other things so
anyway guys seriously thank you so much we
know you both have a chess match to go play
and uh your your earnings
will go toward great causes so
best of luck to you both and hey caro and
i will see you guys on the other side great
all right that was that was uh pretty funny
definitely definitely clothing and food and
electricity and water come before chess
but maybe maybe chess is fit for that
you know but i was gonna say on the flip side
even if you don't have um you know electricity
or internet one of the great things about chess
is you can buy an actual just a small pocket chest
chest set or wooden board plast pieces and um
is one of one of those things that you don't
actually need electricity or internet to play
resident eight 250 bucks there were multiple
hundred dollar donations guys we're gonna get
there let's get there let's get to our goals we're
on track and this is super exciting the day haiti
sounds amazing as does secure populaire either
way uh remember the 15 goes to the winner so if
if we raise the full amount it would actually
be thirty thousand dollars um and uh we've got
fifteen thousand seven and a half percent to the
runner-up so either way these guys have already
done some good work and we'll see we'll see just
how far we can go let's remind you of all the
other charities that were chosen because every one
of these is getting some money no matter what even
if uh your particular charity ie as a streamer or
player um didn't finish in the top of the money no
matter what the the distribution uh will will make
sure that every single one of these organizations
gets at least some sort of uh funding from the
community here and from chess.com so all right hey
cara we've we've been ready for this we've talked
it through it's rainn wilson versus sardoche i
don't even know what to say i can't wait and uh
final thoughts before our last break and then come
back for the games yeah i think it's just going
to be it's going to be a really exciting matchup
um i think the one thing is sardoche i i
could tell when they were talking before
he's perceiving reign to be stronger than um than
reigns performance has been so i think for sardo
she's felt a lot a lot of the weight feeling
like the big favor i think he perhaps does not
feel like the favor in this match um even though
i think he is a big favorite um so it could be a
lot easier from psychologically to relax and just
uh focus on playing his best shots well they were
teasing each other and sardoche was teasing
rain about the stalemate yesterday and rain
saying he didn't mean to but you know who knows
the banter there well i mean hashtag paid actor
exactly uh but uh should we share
any of the charity idea that rain
asked you to do probably not i okay this is uh
this is this isn't cycuno stream so uh it is
we'll keep our clothes on and we'll just leave
it at that don't go anywhere everyone it's the
final game final match excuse me of pogchamps
3 presented by grip6 in just a couple minutes
it's the final game final match excuse me
of pogba champs three presented by grip six
in just a couple minutes what are those
charities the final game goals oh shoot oh yeah
i'm serious i'm i was totally not spying on the
actual broadcast we are watching gotham chess
of course this is d no i'm so looking forward
to the finals between saradosh and rayne wilson
i've been watching the interview obviously
and their discussion about the charities they
are supporting what happened what
happened here can someone tell me
this game bullet chess obviously larry plays
this move gotham chess with the white pieces
now he tweeted the screen capture of my
stalemate can we tweet this queen to g7 g7
all right he had like three seconds
left and he wanted to flag his opponent
he wanted to flag his opponent maybe maybe it
makes him feel even better that he won on time
without the queen imagine imagine playing the
botus gambit where he has three seconds left
on the clock three seconds left 65 000 people
tweeting my name is anand really nice to meet
all 65 000 of you i've been a coach for pogchamps
and you may have seen me on some of the shows but
i'm really looking forward to today's watch party
here at my channel and the main show of course by
danny and hikaru this has been such a fascinating
event i've been saying it so many times on my own
streams that pog champs is one of my favorite
events and i've been to a few events not to brag
but i have been playing chess my whole life
so i know how to how it feels from some of the
some of the most known tournaments i've
been to either as a competitor or later
the last six seven years i spent working on
a lot of chess broadcast such as commentary
i've been to the chelsea olympiad a bit to norway
chess white kansai grunges tour world championship
between magnus and fabian or carrion i was lucky
to be hosting it in london with judith polgar so
i think when i compare those events to pogchamps
and i say that pogchamps is one of my favorites
out of all these events it's for a reason it's
such a different event it makes chess more
accessible i truly think that pogchamps is a door
to everybody to enter in the chess world because
when grandmasters play that's one of of
course the highest level of chess but it
can feel intimidating to watch a chess broadcast
because the players are so much above the viewer's
level that it's difficult to understand
fully what's going on and with pogchamps
well and even though i'm not really sure how
rain would feel about being cast as the sith
hicaro this is some pretty good pretty good
fan artwork here right yeah this is really
really nice artwork um by i who's this one by
don laboot louboutin i think yeah but yeah it's
really really well done you see rain here you
see sardo's you see kevin border you see um
you see chiyu uh then there's yoda i'm
not quite sure who yoda is exactly but
um there's yoda here too yeah i i the face has
been doctored in some way but maybe people can
let us know either way that's some pretty good
stuff from a guy who knows fan artwork icaro
has his own subreddit pretty much dedicated to
the memes his fans make but that's pretty good
especially when you look at rain's hat here
he car the chess wars hat um and uh and it is
it is chess wars and we are ready to roll i think
sardo sent it up his final prayers to the chess
god save your breath sardosh i've been praying to
the chess gods for years look where it's gotten me
mm-hmm viva la france that's what that's
all i'm going to say i bet everything on
i just bet everything on sardo so he better not
let me down okay well um picard have you ever
prayed to the chess guys did they answer your
prayer or not mine is that what happened um no
i mean generally i don't do that i think the only
thing i will say is that sometimes there are some
superstitions i have you know i think i've noticed
sardosh has al has worn the same shirt right
yeah he's worn the same shirt during every match
so he does i don't maybe he just wears the same
shirt every day because i mean we know there's a
certain other uh french-speaking streamer who does
that so maybe maybe i mean starters is trying to
just just trying to model after him but i do think
sargeras has worn the same shirt for every match
we should ask him afterwards especially if he wins
if that's the reason it's because he's he's uh
he's superstitious well sardoche plays e6 which
is i'll just be honest not a move order reign and
i looked at um for his b3 system which um gonna
be interesting to see um and uh rain rain has
always liked this b3 idea against the uh sicilian
it worked out really well even maybe better than
people thought it would against michelle and and
uh in his first game but but it has its drawings
for charlie charlie too and against charlie too so
we'll see sardos clearly did some work kevin
bourdee was talking to me on slack this morning
i think it was a little bit of trash talk but
i'm too thick to get it you know me carl i don't
even you know know what a lot of things are
right anyway um so be three players here good
what is the idea behind what sardo's just playing
i'm trying to figure out because he clearly is
expecting b3 in some order here yeah so what
is sardosh expecting i think the idea is d5 and
d4 becomes a problem for white and i and i don't
know that rain will be ready to deal with that um
anyway i think the idea for black is to get
d5 and d4 in to make bishop b2 feel like
kind of a lost boy over there right but after
bishop b2 d5 pawn takes pawn takes bishop b5
it's already very tricky so i'm kind of
wondering what they look like it's hard
for me to believe that sardosh has not looked
at this ahead of time it was almost impossible
um that they haven't looked at some some version
of this well reigns taken his time here down to
eight minutes and 30 seconds and does finally play
bishop e2 i do like that he's thinking it through
because it's not a line we've looked at but
we'll see how he handles it by the way community
thank you for the donations crushing it and it's
amazing to see where we're getting um so far
pretty pretty oh i don't like e5 yeah and that's
a month go ahead go ahead no you first chipotle
sensei just donated a thousand dollars oh my
geezer snaps chipotle sensei first of all if there
actually is a chipotle sensei is there a burrito
school and can i learn how to roll a fat burrito
that was good laugh no it's not about that it's
just i was going and it was a completely different
train of thought and then we started talking
about a donor instead of about the chest like
i was just seeing about the chest and then someone
would go off on a completely different condition
we talked about this structure and eventually
you know in a lot of positions it can be very
effective especially if you know if we use our
imagination and get everything we want but this
is definitely going to be hard to deal with
if black gets d4 and this pawn becomes weak so
um i think sardosh has definitely won
the opening battle in terms of prep here
i'm not so sure i'll tell you why because this
is kind of turned into an advanced french in a
sense and starters has only played the sicilian
so the whole structure of where the pawns are
for black on f7 e6 d5 objectively it's very good
for black but stardust does not play the french
so i'm not actually actually so sure that it's
as good as we think it is even though objectively
position is great for black okay yeah no i agree
and rain takes there i think it's because he just
wants to get d4 shout out to blake with the 420
non-auspicious donation really appreciate it
and even c3 so as much as this is not the ideal
setup i do like that rain is going for an idea
that we talked about which we i you know i did
advise him this is a structure you can shoot for
obviously we hoped to have a light square
bishop in some of those positions which
you know it's not going to be as good for him but
at least he's sticking through with a plan right
right exactly yeah so this is what i expected uh
rain to do after he played e5 was trying to get it
back into a sort of advanced front structure
the with the connect four from b2 c3 d4 e5
versus f7 e6 d5 so objectively very good for black
but starters doesn't play the french so i really
do like this i mean i do like the start from rain
i don't think it's as bad as we we we assume it is
at a more advanced level because again at this
level players usually they prepare one opening
so when you think about the sicilian very rarely
does it transpose into a french structure like
yep um there might be a this is c3 which ludwig
had where it can get like that but otherwise it
doesn't generally turn into them well and you
highlighted that sardoche maybe not a fan of
closed positions so maybe that works out okay for
rain but shout out to brian with a 500 donation
and then i-9a jc coy on youtube with a 300
donation we're doing it guys we're we're getting
closer to 40 40 000. honestly if we reach 50 000
and all 100k comes out of chess.com's pocket i
would be thrilled it's all coming out of eric's
paycheck our ceo so let's make it and by the way
danny more magic okay back to normal i am going
to research this shenanigans and get back to you
we'll see if rain could play before no go ahead
go ahead no i was going back to the chest i know
that's like a twist ending you didn't see coming i
was focused on the chest good no i was saying yeah
so just just make sure to um i mean just just
just buy a mug with your picture on and give
it to your wife can i get that bug at the store
at the hicaro store uh i don't i don't have this
in my merch yet no ah you need one a magic mug
at the hikaru store right all right um so back
to the chest do you think sardis is gonna find
bishop b5 here or not to stop away from castling
yeah it it okay objectively it is better for black
everyone because of the light square bishop that
that white does not have this could be huge and
honestly if if sardosh saw a move like bishop b5
that could be a really big thorn for rain in this
position to stop castles not sure if he'll find it
yeah if he finds bishop b5 he's in really really
good shape but he plays knight f5 which i like
also it's a good move good solid move to go bishop
e7 and castle your king again objectively very
very good position for black and i i would say for
starters the one good thing is even though it's
it's a little bit close there is an open file yeah
so it's not completely closed in the way that his
games against ludwig or his games against benji
were so i think he's looking very good so far
well even though you and i will probably still be
doing commentary over him let's remind the whole
french community he is streaming and listening
to sardosh for the first time today um we uh we
appreciate the audience there way to go coming
out and supporting your boy and um he is focused
he is very quiet though
place bishop b4 your thoughts on that move
if he's threatening bishop e5 what a trick
yeah i think it's a completely
reasonable move probably not the
best move but nothing wrong with it at all
very very reasonable and nothing wrong with
a username like turnberg when they're
donating 100 bucks thank you so much
now i was a3 is a good move by by rain now i think
i'm kind of curious to see will starters go back
to e7 or will they go to a5 and actually in a
way i kind of prefer a5 i think it's a little
bit easier um to get the bishop to b6 it feels
like the piece placement is pretty good for black
here yeah and frank quickly plays b4 which is a
good move but he still hasn't developed i think
the question will be who who kind of coordinates
first right does brain get the night out
and find a plan with a rook on the c file
or does sardosh get the c file and get some
threats going on on the light squares like
the square c4 is a very good one uh for black
agreed again it's hard to get a knight to c4
though you can't really get a knight to c4
so because you can't get a knight to c4 um i
i don't think it's really a weakness for one
moment oh my god agar we gotta just shout out
because i think the community's gonna make sure
that chess.com pays that 100k we just got a one
thousand dollar donation from freeze four two a
five hundred dollar donation from resin eight
two hundred dollars from float along another
hundred bucks from air hodelkin and a hundred
bucks from em copeland you guys um awesome
it is awesome danny i will say one thing though i
think it's hadouken not hadoken this is uh twitch
okay thank you you know you have played street
fighter right oh like right hadouken yeah you kick
i i remember that i could do like down down a
b and then like blanket would go into
a fiery ball and kick ryu in the face
are you are you talking about dawson or something
i don't know which character you're talking about
but anyway um all right all right so a5 play
this is actually a big a big head move from
andreas just because he recognizes that he
really doesn't want the pieces to get cramped
on the queen side so playing a5 that's that's a
very good move rain really should just kind of
that's a good move i think in response he's trying
to build on it although if andrea sees bishop a4
owie yeah bishop a4 is a very good move
um so bishop a4 here is completely fine
black can also trade and move the queen
yeah if he sees bishop before with queen c4
thank you louis cause nisky for 100 um but rook
c1 if reign gets rook c1 i mean the position is
still very tricky and the one thing i'll observe
is sardocia's time rain was down a minute and a
half but we have seen that completely turn around
yeah exactly yeah so rain is um rain is doing fine
here i think rook c1 is a pretty good move if he
can get it in um the the issue for sardo shearer
is that it can't really attack the pawn on b4 here
um maybe you can take and go
queen but white has knight c5 here
yeah and i'm wondering if
sardosh's time taking is him
feeling like he lacks a plan or if he's just
nervous i think he does have several kind of
good logical moves but maybe he's worried about
about knight to c5 and just doesn't see bishop a4
yeah no it is possible i mean i think bishop a4
does a lot of queen d3 though so it's still very
much a game um i don't like you know i have to say
though i feel like it's easier for rain to play
than it is for sardosh to play here just based
on the placement of the bishops and the knights
um right so in a way i would rather be uh
i would kind of almost rather be white here
because it feels like black i mean sardosh
is down wow he finds it though good move yeah
now will he see queen d3 queen c4 will he see
queen c4 here this is actually the moment of truth
um yeah will he see queen c4 i think after queen
c4 black is quite a bit better um i could be wrong
of course but i feel like queen c4 is a very
strong move here i'm kind of impressed that
it's not that rain found queen d3 but he played
it so fast carl i think that that's a good sign
for rayne just that he saw he saw how dangerous
the pin was and is maintaining a time advantage
real quick we got to keep shouting out uh low
cu zn 500 bucks dan cakes love that 100 bucks
mm armor 100 bucks armor armor wow i'm okay
potts blitz 250 bucks and mr p pg with 100 bucks
i'm sure you know these names carl you've raised
money for charity more than anybody uh maybe
anybody on twitch over the last month to be honest
but certainly anyone in the chess community but
these guys coming through the whole community
thank you everyone gustavo with 150 bucks just
now this is awesome well i i would actually uh
in terms of someone who's done an amazing job
raising money for charity i would actually point
to sardosh and the french community streamers who
i think it was at the end of end of last year
i could have my dates wrong but they raised uh
seven million dollars for unicef i believe it
was if i'm not i think it was unicef maybe i'm
wrong but i think it was unicef um god but they
raised seven million dollars for charity um or no
it's amnesty amnesty that's what it was not yes
it was amnesty wrong one uh yeah so they raised
they raised seven million dollars seven seven
million dude though um destroying computers
just donated twelve hundred dollars thirty twelve
hundred thirty four dollars and fifty six cents
wow and uh though um yeah pick or you're lying
pick what you're lying 150 bucks um i went to the
school for kids who don't read good so apologies
if i can't just you know pronounce your name
correctly on camera icaro take us through what's
going to happen here rayne i don't think saw queen
c4 as evidenced by the fact that he's he's really
taking his time here what does white need to do
this is a really tricky moment but there's only
one move which is trading queens right because
and then you've got to find nice by way 492.
i'm actually not sure which one's better both
are playable i think but i don't know why he's
thinking here now one thing that i would say
especially in rapid chess and blitz chess is
if you're in a situation where there's only
one move you just play the move yeah um and
then you think on the next turn but you don't
spend your time now thinking before you play
the move you sort of there's only one option
you always just play it immediately and then you
think on the next turn in a slow game you can do
it the other way but um but in a rapid game or
blitz game that's generally the correct process
yeah no you're right especially from
a practical point of view it just
no matter what why take that time because you
can't anticipate future critical moments where you
need that time so i agree this is a nervous moment
for rayne wilson where he's he's he's nearing two
minutes taken on the clock and still hasn't played
the only move oh oh he plays knight c5 it's still
it's it's a good move it's still a move though he
can play the other order i would have traded them
on knight c5 he can still do it this way too
though okay no you're right it's not a blunder
and nell or dosh with three and a half minutes
happy 100 bucks one great buffalo 500 bucks
bellian 500 bucks tillal t-i-l-a-l 500 bucks and
omnipot 250 bucks you guys are doing it you're
going to make chess.com pay up we're going to
reach that 50 000 marker which means 100k from
chess.com 150 000 total to charity is what we're
on pace for thank you for helping us get there
wow amazing that's amazing um the charities are
amazing it's just it's been a great day so far
and um we're really close i
think to that critical moment
in this first game where something is going to
happen something dramatic is going to happen
yeah we're going to you mean the e-bell
bar and danny falls out of his chair okay
i don't think we're gonna have those kind of bar
swings i think both players are strong enough that
we'll see some mistakes but we're not
gonna see someone hanging a queen for
example i just don't think that's gonna
happen um in this match they both look so
focused knight takes d3 so you're good at
evaluating players look at the time danny look at
the time all right what look at the time wow g5
is either a great move or terrible move i don't
know which one but it does he does recognize that
white needs both of these defenders to hold and
so maybe he's trying to trick rain but rain isn't
tricked in fact he fires right back what a move g4
yeah g4 is a great move um but the clock
look at the clock two minutes for sarah dosh
like i said sardosh the one issue as i've pointed
out is that when he gets low on time he can get
nervous and bad things can happen um so that's
the one thing that's really going against him
here in this game so so reign is looking very good
also i would say that i felt like in the end game
um now it was only ludwig mind you it was only
in the match against ludwig but we did it it
felt like outplay he outplayed sardosh in the
end game um so there is potentially hope there
for reign as well that he has he has better
opportunities as we get later into the game
well i was going to ask you before g5 and g4
happen because you're good at evaluating whose
position is easier to play and sometimes that's
indicative regardless of who's better but i think
we're seeing that white's position is just easier
and and sardoch's is about to be under two minutes
i think i you know one thing i would say is i
think in this case it's a double-edged sword
i think it's easier for for like one side on
their turn basically um it feels like it can
swing back and forth though in this game like
the easy moves like now if starters takes and
goes night before the pressure's back on rain yeah
nightbeat rate moves right before this would be
highly problematic for white's position
um my producer can't even keep up with you
guys you're going to get us to 50 50k splat
with 500 bucks kessler with 250 uh zidw with
300 cocoa butter 100 bucks and pinchata with
120 and sardoche with knight to b4 this is a
big moment this could be the game right here if
reign doesn't solve this problem correctly akaro
absolutely and i'm not surprised that sardosh
found it it was it was a move that was sort
of screaming to be played and um and now for
rain he has to find which rook square to where
to move his rook rookie two is actually
a great move by the way fantastic move
so sardo should should look to take advantage
of the a file here even something like bishop b5
and offering the trade that's
one of the fastest ways to take
advantage of disconnected pieces but
he plays knight c2 is this ray brook
again not so clear though because black can
take and go rook a2 it still still is unclear i
guess this rain doesn't play rook a4 anyway play
something more straightforward like rook c1 um
yeah i think rook c1 is probably the the
move that he'll play i could see wow okay
but you said this is this is actually not
as easy as it looks because of rook a2
right exactly so it remains very much a game still
now sardo sure needs to not panic and just take
the rook um and i think he will i think he will
take the rook here but he has to find rook a2
that's the critical move yeah um and will he find
it he plays this okay he takes c2 of course the
biggest issue is still on the clock for sardosh
i mean obviously rain playing well and sardo's
playing well but the clock is the real problem
yeah well but now it kind of goes the other way
i would say actually for cerritos it becomes a lot
easier to play because you can't move the rook on
any two you got to keep it there to prevent
the bishop from moving so now you can focus
only you can focus on the other rook and just go
for an idea with the other rook so in a way it's
it's it's swung back the opposite direction where
for sarah dosh the moves are a lot easier now
yeah especially if you find some some plan
to get the rook involved like if he sees rook
c8 and b6 or something to take advantage of the
pin what you said is really clear and that's
why rain is thinking here although that's
a good move rain recognizes he needs help
he's going to bring the king in
yeah so i mean rain is looking really really
good at this at this point um but we'll see what
a move by sardosh trying to win the bishop
but rain is going to be one square in time
yeah king d3 is just in time here again
though i don't think it's i don't think
it's over though i i don't think it's quite
that simple um well let's let's see what he
what he plays he plays rook b4 okay now will
rain play bishop c3 is also a big question mark
yeah because if he doesn't there's
even like rook b3 check stuff so
mateo with 500 bucks dmac dc 200 we are almost at
48 000 which means we're almost at 150 000 total
wow um you know what i was going to
say about rain one of the reasons
that i thought that sardosh was a favorite
is because i felt like rain has not played
a complete game from start to finish and
it feels like this is the first game yeah
yeah we're like he didn't get a big advantage out
of the opening but he's made subtly good moves
like playing playing this uh a3 b4 knight two b3
playing g4 taking on g5 taking the bishop on a4
this feels like the first really complete
game that rain has played in the event so
yeah agreed yeah because some of the games he
won early were partly in due to you know your
opponent blunders or rook on h8 or or those
sort of things but this is this is definitely
maybe his most complete game and and now he's
got sardoche nearing under a minute exactly yeah
let's see what sardos does here he takes on c2
okay let's see what happens okay but now king
b3 and you can trap the rook and go and bring
your knight back yeah the biggest problem
with rook c4 is it okay brain brings the
sardochi needs to get the rook out of dodge asap
rook a4 right uh oh okay rain misses king b3
which would have won the rook outright after
knight d2 right agreed yeah so uh this is
i mean again if rain can find knight b3 a5 he
is winning here um if he doesn't find an idea
to try to attack that pawn b7 early though
and black can get the king to like g6 or g5
yeah it starts getting very it starts getting
tricky and already i don't like f4 because
after king g6 black can play h5 at
some moment yeah wrong side of the
board agreed in fact the worst move here for
rain would be a move like h4 allowing h5 right
you're totally right if rain focuses on this side
of the board it's the wrong area and if black
strikes with h5 this this is still a wild finish
right i agree so that and that's the other thing
i would say is so i would feel like more at the
intermediate level or beginner level if there's
an open file i think actually having a rook
against the bishop tonight generally is preferable
um because it's a lot easier to just use the
word versus coordinating the bishop in the night
now seize it and now it gets spicy this is gonna
get super spicy sardosh might even end up because
at less experienced levels everyone even though
the night and bishop are objectively better
look at what's happening rain is rain is not it's
it's wait he didn't play what what whoa whoa whoa
what yeah they're both just missing
g4 it's hanging what are they doing
what the g4 is hanging on the board oh my
gosh what is going on here oh man that was
and now he now he almost is losing the pieces
i think sardo's just panicked i honestly think
sergio is just panicked there he saw his clock
was getting low and he just panicked yeah wow
he just missed his winning opportunity we didn't
think we'd see ivelbar swings like that but now
if right right if reign finds the plan of getting
the knight in then white should still be winning
but he's already missed it a few times and in fact
here you go again what i was trying to say is it's
so much harder to coordinate the knight and bishop
for less experienced players than it is to play
with the rook and we're seeing that here even
though reigns better he's not coordinating the
miners the way you know a master would obviously
yeah that's the thing it's like because you think
about it it's two for one yeah and now you don't
take the bishop on e1 it's important just like
water is broke oh my god oh my gosh if sardoshi
had taken the pawn or given check he might have
come back and won that game you panicked you know
it was like sir dosh i think it's just too much
too much in the way of nerves he was defending for
so long yeah that when he had the opportunity just
he eventually cracked under the pressure of the
situation that's what it is dude i was just about
to predict that sardosh would give this check and
that rain would play 92 and black would play king
of three i would thought that was going to happen
but you know what elsa is going to say danny
that's the second time sardosi has done this where
he's missed a backwards knight capture on each one
he also did this in his game against nico in the
first match of the of the group stage we're in
that second game he was completely winning and
then he just hung a bishop on each one where
there's knight g3 takes h1 so it's not the first
time he's done this bishop is a good move because
i was just about to say the last chance sword
does is to get a knight in bishop mate somehow
but i think bishop g3 confirmed yep yeah i
don't see it happening here yeah not anymore
wow he's gonna get like one i think i think
he'll get rid of one pawn but not both
um and then just the one pawn is just one pawn
too much there have been more than a dozen of
you who've donated north of 100 that i haven't
shouted out jungle bird i see the last one so
everyone who's donated everyone thank you so
much i think we're going to get our goals and
and do it with a game display wow very tough
for sardosh i mean again this is i think what
i would say is his big problem was he got way
too low on time and when he's gotten low on
time he sometimes steals too much pressure right
we're not outside the realm of wild stalemates
at this point reign still struggling to
coordinate the knight bishop which is
which is um a normal thing uh wording the
night bishop properly takes a lot of experience
but here reign is probably overthinking it
probably just needs to get the king involved
yeah so king f4 and king e5 and white
is uh and white should be winning here
so i think the key here is that yeah king
e5 and it's not stylemate the king just gets
in and you take on e6 and d5 yeah one
square left for black or dosh unlucky
so let's see let's see um yeah
yeah just knight takes pawn
very rough very rough for um for sara dosh i mean
like he he he really kept it together but i think
it was just the comb it was the pressure of being
worse on the board and the pressure of the clock
as well and just it got to him he just he couldn't
keep it together past a certain point um and it
was like right when he was back it was right
when it turned around the blunder occurred um
so i yeah you know i think i think
it's just one of those things where
i don't even know how you're supposed to
look at it because he's done this twice now
with the backwards night capture but maybe
there's just some way to just double double
check and see i don't see where your knight
is or something i'm not i'm not really sure
how he can do it but the fact that it's not
the first time is is um is a bad sign yeah
yeah well and he he had gotten himself in
a position where the rook was was flexing
on the knight bishop and rain and we talked about
sardosh missing the opportunity but you know rain
was going backwards with the pieces and the night
and bishop were not doing what they were supposed
to so really unfortunate to see sardosh miss
the the night capture and unless reign pulls
uh let's reign pulls a stalemate here oh my god
when he played 25 for a second i thought he did
oh man look at the sardoc oh man yeah well i mean
i mean we all we all knew it was it was a good
job yesterday that's all i'm gonna say yeah he's
clapping frustrated but we still have another game
to go and i still believe our prediction of who
the faster of the two is in terms of sardocia is
correct so if the frenchman can get a dub in game
two and go to a tiebreaker all bets are off so
don't go anywhere it is the final regulation game
of pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6 when we return
first the frenchman they gotta stop
bringing in 1500s bro oh oh gee oh
uh you know what if that's cool with them
too um not to say that like i'm complaining
because i was weaker uh just that you know it's
more exciting when they blunder more is all as i'm
saying it's just a little more when people blunder
a lot it can be thrilling um so chess.com it uh
seems like our time's coming to an end here
let me tell you it's been nice it's been uh
something i'll remember for a while i'll cherish
these moments we have these three minutes at a
time these windows where i pretend i don't know
you're coming but i know every time i plan all of
my content even down to the reactions i'll watch
the video then re-react to it on stream just so
i have the timing down a little bit better but
although it's the end of pog champs life will move
on chess a beautiful game that brought us together
for this short few weeks of time and it'll die
these moments we spent together but
the memories they won't el doido
other moments i can still only remember
xqc losing in six moves that wasn't even
that spock chambers like literally a year and a
half ago at this point but still it was fun and
if there's one thing i want you guys to take
away from this if there's one thing that at
the end of the day is the most important
lesson to take away from all of pogchamps
it's that every single month you'll have a twitch
prime that becomes available look hey ludwig back
at it again ah click on the subscribe button
and if it says subscribe free grip it and rip it
hey [ __ ] i'm taking 10 days off from streaming
straight up that's a fact 10 days all right i'm
going to drop minimum like 15 000 subs aka triple
what's our dose ever had in his [ __ ] life sorry
more like start okay i'm sorry actually
sorry dosh i hope you do bring it back but
yeah so just double check boys double check hey
gripping a rip it on your favorite chess creator
um you know but the boats had sisters lost like
uh 500 600 700 to me in chess yesterday give it to
them or [ __ ] give it to me i don't care it's up
to you guys it's up to you guys just make sure to
grip and rip it i'm just hey i'm not here to give
you any content anymore i'm out of this tournament
just.com [ __ ] me they gave me black pieces
first i deserved white this is my shield period
i don't got to give content we're over just
succulent professionally and romantically
i will say i will be coming back
to chess even though i'm on break
the only day i'm streaming is the uh
the uh what is it twitch rivals event
twitch rivals event i'm in it with let me
tell you a very secret gm okay let's just
say the game of chess would be a lot different
without him okay is that does that ring a bell
it would be very different indeed i
would even argue that we are a bit
goaded
end it zero seconds introducing the grip six
belt the only belt on the market with the no
gut pinch guarantee the grip 6 is so light and
thin that you'll barely even notice it's there
it's smooth low profile design makes this belt
the most comfortable belt in the world overly
confident much you're damn right because on top
of being the most comfortable belt in the universe
each grip 6 belt comes with our a3 gear and damn
tee meaning if you don't like any belt for any
reason at any time or in any condition you can
just contact us and we'll give you a full refund
and we are back with pogchamps three presented
by grip spicks grip six excuse me speaking of
which grip6 wants to thank everyone who watched
pogchamps especially those that signed up for
the giveaway did it you're awesome and you still
have a chance to do it but it's your last chance
go to go.chess.com grip6 and use code pogchamps
20 or 20 off belts while it's wool socks
be sure to get their last chest belts and wallets
remaining before they're gone because they won't
be back not kidding go do it here we go all
right picaro it's winner go home for sardosh
we know the french faithful will be
cheering him on rain taking a sip of
something that's not sponsored
and we're going to move forward
yeah so i think you know the one thing i would
say about rain is his openings with black have
been very shaky um against e4 so i'm very curious
to see if sardosh is actually is gonna switch up
and play e4 here on move one because for example
his game um he had a game i think in the group
stage it was a little bit shaky and then he was
completely busted in that game against charlie
uh in their second game in in the modern but
sardosh actually just plays d4 and bishop f4 which
i'm kind of surprised to see um considering the
situation like i kind of would have thought that
maybe his coach uh like kevin boardy would have
been like okay if you lose the first game with um
with uh with with uh uh white i'm
sorry what isn't starters higher rated
yeah shouldn't the higher rated player
have been white in the first game
i don't think i don't think in the regular
one i think i think it's in the tie break
what oh it's not based on rating oh it's not
based on oh okay it's not based on reading
okay all right okay okay i just i think we
said i just like wait a second it's 14 40
panic attack i know you're watching go
get a life ludwig stop watching chess.com
yeah sorry i was just like i was just like
it just took me like wait a second something
seems wrong about this but okay all right um i
agree with you i'm surprised he didn't play e4
um because again i feel like one thing that's
really important is when you think the players
are evenly matched in a must win game i think
based on rain playing d6 every every game
um if sorry i should play d4 and e4 you could have
gotten a very good position with the same kind of
opening setup or something very similar to what
charlie did against rayne um as opposed to just
just sticking to a system and it is the final
match so it kind of is one of those things where
you should go you should go all in so it's kind
of interesting that he didn't he didn't switch
it up but it is understandable because again you
don't really know how the first game will go but i
think you should have multiple options especially
the final game of the of the champions bracket
agreed right and rain has played this you know he
there's no way he was going to vary up but just to
complete the circle of my full disclosure what we
looked at the only thing rated i really looked at
was to make sure he wasn't going to get crushed by
the grop i showed him what to do against the grub
and that was it otherwise i was like otherwise you
got to play your modern and i reminded him don't
fall for the same trap you did against charlie but
other than that it was like hey man do your thing
and reigns approach in general uh oh double
fee and kettle sometimes that can get him in
trouble but reigns approach in general is he
just kind of wants to get to the middle game
he's not into the opening stuff so that's why
most of my opening advice is how not to lose um
he's going to play the hippopotamus
with e6 and 97.97 oh wow
this is the thing rain loves but this is gonna
this could get him in big trouble and i think this
might have been what kevin was coaching sardoshan
like look if he gives you the center take it and
don't apologize yeah exactly so um yeah i mean
pretty pretty balanced position white has much
more space in the center of the board it's very
hard to play here um for both sides i feel like
because neither side really has a clear break um
black can't play e5 like black normally does uh
f5 is probably too dubious because of knight
g5 so it's going to be interesting to see
um how rain how rain reacts here it's also going
to be really important that sardosh keeps it
together though he's really got to stay focused
um and i think not fall too far behind on the
clock so i think the clock is really what hurt
him the most in the first game yep um plays nice
c6 which is a struggle i think one of the things
rain is worried about is this idea of of bishop h6
with h4h5 understandably so it's certainly an idea
but my guess is the reason he played knight c6 is
because he's about to play queen d7 and i'm gonna
try to castle long if i'm just reading into reigns
brain um although isn't e5 kind of strong
here for black yeah e5 would be great
yeah queenie through is not
not a great move um by sardosh
but clearly we know who the coaches are yeah well
only i i just knew because rain really hates this
idea and the moment it was set up and he played
knight c6 i was just reading it that rain rain
has made up his mind that this is his plan he's
probably not even looking for e5 but i am looking
for donors blunder wonder 251 and float along
with his second 200 donation thank you everyone
right now sardo she needs to be careful that if
frank castles queen side he does not play b4 and
blunder e5 this is actually very important
here yeah because rain will find it then
yeah for sure for sure yeah i think rain is
not i always wonder if you won't find it here
but you slow it down so maybe you're
right maybe he's pausing but i think
i think if e5 happens you're right then sardoche
will really regret what he did here right
yeah this is i mean it's it's hanging on an
edge already very early in the second game
so let's let's see let's
see um what is it gonna do
okay well i gotta give a shout out because we did
it i mean resonate 500 bucks j j sutz 200 bucks
we're about to cross 50 000 which again we doubled
it this morning chess.com doubled its match to
make sure we would give away all 100k which means
we have given away 150 000 and maybe we'll keep
going awesome awesome okay so the moment of truth
will sardosh play b4 or not because the e5 is a
huge problem here um now it's now it's actually
game over black gets the e5 in it's game over
so sorry to move the bishop away let's show the
tactics so it went oh he played it what car was
pointing out is that you can't even take the pawn
on e5 because now not only is this bishop hanging
but because reign is castled this bishop is
hanging so e5 isn't just a positional break
as hikaru is saying it's it's a tactical
nightmare for white because of this idea
will he do it i think he will
well i think now he's you've kind of forced his
hand right because he's already got castled and
so unfortunately for sardo she's and you can't
even deny the trade because if you move the bishop
first then we take right yeah and there's also
knight takes d4 with e5 which is also very good
oh yeah now but rain misses it oh i think
i think he's thinking the way sardocious
sardosa is thinking i gotta check mate black
and rain's like well i'm gonna have to put my
pieces over here and checkmate white and
obviously both sides are just neglecting
how how problematic the dark squares are right
now with this uh-huh yeah no it's very true
um if i'm sardosh you gotta move the bishop
here you gotta go bishop g3 or bishop h6
yeah you can also play b5 here but i i it's
really important that sardosh moves that bishop
really really important
i mean you can also go b5 here
as well but i think i mean the
one thing i would say though is it's such
a non-standard position and the fact that
it's not um okay b5 i like now will rango
knight a5 or not is also a big question
mm-hmm um he get away with this i mean he
can but i don't think he'll see it now if
he's already missed it a few times yeah i i
don't think so either he does play ninety-five
yep good move because otherwise white gets upon
avalanche with a4a5 whereas now white pushes
the pawn to a4 the knight is stopping it from
going further up the board yeah inadvertently
kind of critical even though black uh meaning rain
missed e5 for many moves it's still a really good
position here for the night um right so i mean
i think okay e5 not the best move but not a bad
move either not a bad move i think if rain finds
knight f5 he's doing very well knight five is not
a logical move here at all though um so i really
do in a way like e5 because it also gives a much
sort of there's a lot less of an opportunity
for um for black to find a clear-cut idea to
be much better or winning outright winning here
um and so if rain doesn't see night of five
knight of five i think is the only move that's
really good here everything else and i think uh
ooh i don't like f5 at all yeah that's a although
although i mean h6 and g5 is very scary here
okay yeah i was going to say this is
rain falling through with his plan but
yeah knight f5 was definitely the move the
one thing we'll say about f5 that's good in
addition to h6 and g5 hecarim is that it
it also over protects this square which
is kind of key right because that was probably
sardosh's next idea was a move like knight e4
right okay anyway yeah so i think here white white
i mean sorrow should castle and try to play c5
but the good thing for sardosh is that this will
be a decisive game this is not a slow game it's
it's very very sharp both kings are going to end
up on opposite sides and it's you know all in for
sardo's share with castles and then yeah kings on
opposite sides of the board and a must-win game is
pretty much what you can ask for right at least
both sides at least you'll have that chance
um yeah so he's got a castle here yeah castle
even if you're putting a rook on c1 that allows
a fork it doesn't matter you've got to find a
way to blow open the c file against the black
king right and c5 here doesn't work it's important
because on black just takes and your knight on c3
is not protected once you recapture that's why
rook c1 is so strong he plays rook d1 okay okay
it's not a bad move either by the way
i think rook d1 is also a playable move
now the question for rayne
the question for reigns will he play h6
go for g5 or will he if he doesn't find
that plan it's very hard to play here it's
it's probably losing if you don't see h6 g5
um so let's let's see what rain does because
this is this is very critical moment i like that
sardosh is has stayed even on the clock very very
important i i think probably in between games he
spoke to kevin is my guest and probably kevin told
him like you can't fall way behind yeah you got to
speed up indeed and knight a4 if he finds that
a4 to go with rook d1 to remove that knight then
then c5 is going to be super scary to stop
so i agree with you this is critical for rain
whether he finds the right plan yeah i
think h6 g5 is almost the only plan that
i see that makes sense here you can maybe go
king b8 and king a8 again looks very dubious
but other than king b8 i mean an h6
he goes knight b3 braves idea i mean
because the problem is of white castles it's
still you're not actually going to win the
pawn on d4 because takes queen 39 d4 and you
run into the logic trick with queen a8 check
um here it's not checkmate now again i'm sure i'm
sure ludwig has very fond memories of that um we
all know that ludwig's watching um but yeah if you
castle take and then take that pawn on d4 there's
queen eight at the end yeah that would be a huge
mistake from rain if he played knight b3 with the
idea of of giving up this bishop in fact even here
now that the queen defends the knight maybe he
played it with some idea of knight c5 which would
have been crazy skeptical but possible but yeah
i was gonna say no he needs to just go right back
to a5 and follow mulligan by the way we're calling
it we've also officially crossed fifty thousand
before it was a little early but we are crushing
it and way to go community thank you so much
also sorry you know the funny thing is sergeants
is sardo's just panicking and losing his mind here
thinking blunder but it's actually a great blunder
yeah because it opens the c file now he doesn't
have to push the pawn if he goes queenie two here
um i think queenie two and white's probably
winning yeah i don't think he'll find it but
the thing is the rook just scoots over to
c1 and there's massive pressure on the file
there's also rook to e1 at some point to put
pressure on the e6 pawn so he blundered a pawn
but if he keeps his wood about him and just goes
very quietly queen to e2 he's doing extremely well
but we had this what was the match we had with
um where the the knight and rook were blundered
but then the c5 oh i was commenting with anna with
rubius and and there was the c file right and um
you're right this is a pawn that while it looks
good could end up being a disaster for rain
exactly i mean again i think for
sardosh plays queen e2 great move
as long as sargeras keeps it together
here and he doesn't doesn't panic and
freak out too much he still is has
a very good chance to win this game
yeah the risk of d5 ray might play d5 but the
risk is then the dark squares are problematic
and you've got new problems um also you you
lock in your bishop on b7 if you play d5
yeah yeah sourdough just needs to take
a deep deep breath and relax now bishop
d3 is very good will he see bishop d3 or will
he go bishop b3 actually both look good to me
well both i mean bishop b3 threatens bishop
takes bishop d3 officially traps the knight
even rook a1 as bad as that is compared to the
other two hikaru knight c2 queen c2 you've got
a7 as a target this is i'm with you that even
though the eval bar or actually bar also likes
white the point is this is a game that is going
to be very hard for black especially in rapid yeah
agreed in fact and now yeah now it's now it's
time reign has to play knight d5 only move here
um to not be losing on the spot you know what this
game reminds me of danny this reminds me a lot of
the game between pokeman and rubius um where that
was the game yeah that was the pokemon had bishop
on f4 and she got like a rook on c1 and there
was a ton of pressure because the king was on
scene and there was that diagonal towards b8 so
that that's what this game reminds me a lot of
to annoyed with 250 and again we
are at 50 400. awesome possum um
i don't know what round this is
okay he finds knight d5 which is
probably the best way to
defend e6 right to be fair
again i i think starters is very much in the
game he just needs to stay calm and and look
look for tactics too like sardo as i've said
before he's done a lot of puzzles i think he has
like a tactics rating of about 2 000. but based
on that he just needs to stay focused and keep
looking for uh for puzzles here looking for the
puzzle solution i should say 2000 puzzles is legit
yeah i mean i think again everybody it's
easier when you do puzzling that's one of
the things about chess that's really rough
is when when you do the puzzle and you know
there's some kind of solution a sequence
of a couple moves that's really really good
it becomes a lot easier to see versus in real time
when you're playing gaming you're not being told
well there's a sequence of moves that's
winning the game um that applies at all
levels act it's not just something that applies
at the at the absolute top um but it but or
yeah um it's one of those things at all
levels people people make those mistakes
takes with the bishop which i guess is the one
way this could backfire for sardosi is if somehow
he keeps trading and doesn't do what you want
if you're a sardosh fan you want you want both
in fact even that move it's kind of a wasted
check maybe you want these rooks on these two
squares here um again it's anyone's game though i
feel like i feel like the the the uh the weakness
of the black king here gives sardosh good
chances regardless even though even though
objectively it was a bad move uh oh he's got rook
c6 he's got rook c6 okay rook c66 huge music c6
well he also cuts off the queen from b5 by
the way which is officially a threat for black
yeah rook c6 is a huge move will he find it if
he finds rick i think he's gonna win this game
what a move and now the only move for reign is
knight c4 to guard the pawn but then 92 removes
the knight i i think sardosh is going to win the
game now yeah i think it's very likely he wins
and the thing we'll applaud too is that he
got this position with time on the clock
and the last game if you missed it everyone
it was the opposite rain had more than six
minutes when sardosh was down to two so this
is a great turnaround for the french faithful
right now will he find 92 is the question
i think he will because now i think he
can tunnel on the pawn on d6 and try to
remove that knight which defends the pawn
i would actually be very surprised if sardos
does not find knight d2 here agreed knight d2
is the move and it is removal of the defender
kind of stuff he's 2 000 on tactics trainer
i think he'll find him even if he doesn't find
it the next move with a move like rook a1 or
i mean you don't want to miss it
but i think that i think that he
will see this idea and it's hard for rayne
to defend this pawn in one move anyway
right i agree well the thing is if rayne gets
moving can go rook c8 all the pressure on the
pawn vanishes in in one move so that's why it's
super critical for starters to play knight t2
here and the reason that i think he'll play it
is because there are no other moves that really
makes sense you can't move your rook on c6 your
bishop on f4 is perfectly placed towards the pawn
um if you move your rook to e1 black just plays
rook e8 so it doesn't feel like there are any
other pieces really you can focus on maybe you
can look at the queen and try to move the queen
but it's just when you look at the placement you
know you can't remove the rook or the bishop and
you can tell that pawn is really weak if you
move it so i think if you focus on and think
about every single piece of piece on the board
you should be able to find the night move yeah
and again great breakdown of the thought process
which i think you know in a lot of these pog
champs you do a good job of and uh okay he doesn't
unfortunately fall short but it was not not a bad
move though they're still yeah because it also
it's the same idea it threatens rook takes c4
right right yup yup sorry about that no it's
all good and i think i think rain probably
we'll see what what he does here but i think
it's it's very tricky very very tricky position
we've got more than 30 000 live viewers
watching on youtube shout out to you guys
over there we don't reach that very often and
76 000 of you on twitch and many others across
this is it well sardo's play rook takes he
does nice i think we're gonna i think we're
headed to overtime oh what is that oh no
what is that by rain yeah oh well now rain
just loses rick takes rook and you just oh
and now you resigned now you just resign
so this was super tough for it was super tough
for raymond because of how sardoch played it i
mean honestly he kept the pressure rook c1 wasn't
as good as knight d2 but in hindsight the idea was
just as strong and and he's going to take this
wow yeah you know i was going to say that um
a lot of credit goes to sergio she kept it
together like you could tell he was really
frustrated when he hung that pawn on c4 um there
are a lot of movements and gesticulations and all
those other things but he kept it together and he
didn't completely lose it and he still made moves
logical moves didn't spend too much time um and
he's gonna he's gonna win this game now i think
well we called it then we said that's going to
be a pawn that he's happy he's gone look at the c
file it's winning in the game and the other thing
is reigns so passive there there are no background
checkmates there's nothing you can do on the queen
side just the texture of the pawn the rook and the
bishop all of white's pieces are very harmonious
here relative to black's pieces so i do think
sarah dosh is going to win this game yeah it would
be very hard to mess up i don't even know how rain
activates here i mean i guess you can play bishop
e7 but if knight f7 comes in the pawn falls anyway
so yeah yeah it's looking uh it's looking great
i think we're right gambit the shrewd gambit
i mean there are a lot of gamuts that
have been invented on twitch so um why not
yeah did dwight schrute play chess
in the office i don't know there
was probably an episode with chess who
knows and will they go rook d6 now yeah
i guess rook d6 queen c7 rook d8 is not so
obvious to spot yeah but i guess you can take
and also play rook b6 there are multiple
solutions if sardo sees rook takes pawn
yeah rook d6 queen c7 rook d8 everyone as cecaro
said wins the queen but if you don't play rook
d8 you play some other random move turns around
because you can lose your own f4 bishop right
but the thing is you can also play rook takes
b6 check as well so factor multiple solutions
gives him more room um if he
takes palm to work to find it
whereas if there's only one solution it can be
i mean you're really hanging on pins and needles
um as far as whether they'll find the move um
but but in a situation like this where there's
multiple solutions afterward takes pawn i do think
he'll win but look at sardos she is actually kind
of panicking again he's not uh he's not playing
work takes pawn he's using a lot of time here
yep so let's see will he find
it or not this is a big question
minute 30 is chicken
yeah yeah i mean if he gets under a buck
i mean it's it could get really tricky
listening listening to the nervous frenchman
right now yeah as i said nerves nerves are
what matt if he keeps the nerves and
just takes that pawn with the rook he's
thanks for the bishop i don't like that okay now
rook c7 though now now rook c7 he should finally
stop and kill rook c7 he'll find ray needed
to play king a8 to keep it confusing right
now
got nervous there for like a second i mean if if
reigning i don't know what would have happened
yeah but yeah yeah he's got he's gonna win now
especially because as i said before it's a bishop
yeah i don't think he's speaking
english or french he's speaking
yeah the good thing is that it's a bishop it's
a it's a bishop so bishop can only attack on you
know the dark dark colored tiles and therefore
uh there's no chance of of sardoch not winning
here it's like 99.99 guaranteed he will win we're
gonna head to uh to blitz gonna be blitz over time
where i think sort of has to be the favorite um
i believe there it does matter who gets who gets
white and i believe sardoch will get white i think
it is decided by raiding but we'll confirm that so
um wow yeah there there's just no way because i
as i've noticed if you get a bishop that's the one
end game where your tricks even even if even
in the consolation bracket if you end up with
like a rook against a bishop the bishop just
does not attack you can only attack on one
color of squares so it's it's not it's it's not
you just you can't create threats with a bishop
so there's just no way that sardoce doesn't win
as sir dosh cleans this up i'll uh i'll clean
up what was a discussion for the community just
so you know the donations were coming in so fast
that the animation fell behind the bar so just
so you know a lot of the donations flashing now
that we already shot out and i and i gave a shout
out to you before you were not being ignored just
you guys got way ahead of the animation so um
so it took a while to catch you up but again
uh thank you to everyone and i think
we're gonna have overtime so um right on
cue there's on poisson in the chat you know
he's the only checkmate on b7 yep but the
bar is accurate in real time just so you
know the bar is accurate for donations
just like uh if it takes a frenchman to not
miss on not win uh miss ambassador right of
course
what he said soccer blue we're headed to
overtime it's arma get it on pog champs
three presented by grip6 style
hicaro and i will be right back
time it's arma get it on pog champs three
presented by grips thank you for the tank
sauce right back we are heading to a tiebreaker
yes oh friends oh i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
go some braille so that is not stream reception
hello everybody i've been watching obviously the
main clash for park champs three between rain
wilson and sardosh what a comeback by sardosh
this whole game was so annoying starting
out let's let's do a bit of recap because
this position it looks like white is doing
fine with the connect four and this attacked
but reign missed his chance that he could
have played e5 he currently pointed this out
on the cover coming from so i think you know
it i think you know it but just a reminder
that this was a beautiful tactical motive
because after e5 the bishop is hanging and
you're threatening to take here if the bishop
moves you capture the poem with the pawn and
that's a fork the queen is hanging the knight is
hanging you're winning one of those pieces and
if white doesn't want to allow this and tries to
take this pawn you take back with the pawn and now
what happens after the capture the pawn is
now an e5 opening up the d5 meaning that now
two bishops are hanging the f4 bishop is hanging
because of the pawn and the d3 bishop is hanging
because the queen and the rook of rain are on the
d5 we can also show it from this perspective i
don't know if that helps or not thank you so much
by the way for the new subscriptions thank you
everyone for being so supportive today you have
been very generous when it comes to the charity
goal on the broadcast and also subscribing here
lottery goes was giving a beautiful prime speech
and then people started subscribing on my channel
thank you so much you really shouldn't have
thunder thank you so much for the five gifted subs
thanks a lot to everybody you're way too kind let
me show the tactical motte from this perspective
from rayne's perspective this is how it looked
e5 is an extremely strong move because of the four
aforementioned reasons bishop and pawn hanging
bishop moves you take it pawn fork pawn takes pawn
takes both bishops are hanging he was gonna win
a piece there's not a single move here that saves
the piece for right another another important hint
that you should aim for something in the center
in a position like this is because dwight's king
is still in the middle of the board if your
opponent hasn't caused that's a huge hint that
you need to open up the center you need to try
to open up these central files because you want
to gain access to that king and make him pay for
not castling make that king pay for not catholic
so this was an opportunity for reign that he
missed the pawn being pushed to e5 would have
basically won the game in a way
because of peace up on this level
after winning the first game it would have been
very tough for sardos to try to make a comeback
from a piece down in a must-win situation thank
you so much ezra's monkey for the five gifted subs
so many of you are subscribing master with the
prime a flying act with the prime the fancy jester
with the prime asteroid with the prime spins of
it the prime puffy panda victor pratt activity 20
gift itself jesus christ is not my birthday i'm
just i'm just a tiny chess creator former chess
player current time broadcaster and streamer
for pogchamps i've been one of the coaches
i haven't coached mr rainwilson nor i have worked
with sardoche but i have coached the girl squad
i've been working with the four
female participants of park gyms 3
as well as the honorary member of the girl squad
that is rubios because i'm i was then assigned to
rubio's honorary member of the girl squad but
pokemane michelle curry nico and code miko have
been the participants i have had lessons with and
i'm freaking proud of each and every one of them
they may not have made it to the championship
bracket finals but michelle and nico wrote a
clash in the consolation bracket so two ladies
two two of the girl squad members made it to
the finals in the constellation bracket and
i'm really proud of them also many of these
participants might be back for pogchamps 4.
for instance rubius wants a rematch against
xqc and as we get set for the final game
remind everybody of how how we got
here in the championship bracket
our dosh he took down huge fan favorite the only
guy who's played in all three pog champs xqc
then you know someone who has just as big of a fan
base here especially in regards to his commitment
to chess you got ludwig he took him down on the
other side you had rain squeaking by charlie
another guy who played in the first pog champs
and then benji fishy the only guy who beat sardosh
but it all comes down to this it's a tie breaker
not armageddon style but 5.0 blitz style between
these two guys for winner take all he caro yeah
so i think it's going to be very uh very exciting
i think the slight favorite is sardosh based on
what we saw in his game against ludwig where he
made some fantastic moves really trust himself
um in in that final final blitz game that they
played so i think service is a very slight edge
based on that but again i i think mostly it comes
down to the nerves and who's able to make moves
and not panic and use too much time at critical
moments and we'll see if either side mixes it up
a little bit right we had the b3 sicilian that
ended up being okay for rain but it wasn't a
great start it it'll be interesting to see what
they do okay i think sardosh is probably going to
go right back to it with some kind of improvement
from kevin if i had to guess yeah i would
definitely agree with that all right so here we go
now once again this is 5-0 so it's it's and the
other thing i would say is i suspect that uh
that sardoch has not played much blitz because
his rating is 1004 whereas rain is 1385 but
but then again rain is 1385 is that based on a
significant significant amount of games or just
like one or two is also it's only based on one
or two in his in his main account he's about 1150
so okay um he's you know what that's based on
it's based on basically whatever armageddon
games he's had here in this event um which
he's won every tiebreaker right that's true
yep okay so let's see okay so bishop e2 well
starters go d4 is a big question mark too
yeah d4 move well i think it's the e457 right
there should be seven completely reasonable so far
i will say i think this this opening is a little
bit favorable to black because i feel like white's
ideas are not so obvious here if white doesn't
play d4 and four's open this diagonal like if
white goes d3 i think blacksmiths are a little
bit easier with like rookie eight and bish buffet
yeah rookie a bishop of fade blacksmiths are
coming easier now you already see reign regretting
the kind of passive development there but i'd say
overall the earliest sign for the sardoche fans
is what we're seeing on the clock which is kind of
what we predicted if it came down to a tiebreaker
sardoche has been the faster player yeah so i
i think certainly yeah rookie eight good move
by sardosh um really for rain he ha it hinges
around whether he pushes his pawn to d4 at some
point if he does not push his pawn to d4 or he
doesn't see the idea quickly here especially
it's going to be very hard to play also when
you look at the clock situation too this is
getting this is getting pretty pretty dicey
already for rain down a minute on the clock
um especially given there's no increments so
there's no help coming right this is like a
this is a wild west style affair especially when
you were just playing a bunch of increment it's
hard to make that adjustment but at the same time
both of these guys have had tie breakers and right
for sardosh it took a tiebreaker to get here you
know so um we know that they know what's in store
right so now will rain finally play d4 the
last moment that he can play d4 will he do it
will he do it if he doesn't starters goes d4 and
you open up the long diagonal and you excavate the
knight on f3 and the pawn on g2 yeah so he does
go d4 good move now 95 is an interesting idea
but again i think it's all coming down to the
clock i think sardosh is he's going to win this
game because of time reign has got to speed up
way too early though to say that it's still 246.
i would say i would say if if rain gets under
one minute on the clock and starters just
has more than two minutes i think i mean the
odds of starters winning go up to like 80 90
but i think rain still has two minutes and 40
seconds that is still a lot of time yeah um no
it's true and and they're both good enough if they
get a huge advantage to probably convert even with
limited time on the clock i would say yes if
someone is up a queen and they have probably
more than 10 seconds maybe i would say 15 to be
be conservative 15 seconds they'll probably be
able to win the game um so so the margin i would
say is you need to get that winning position
but clearly winning position with more than
30 seconds on the clock i think if you have
30 seconds or less there's too much panic involved
and anything can happen um but until then okay now
there's knight e4 which is when 94 is winning for
black well well um and it's a very natural move
will he see it uh okay queen c7 not the best move
but a reasonable move nonetheless 95 has been on
the board for a while for rain but he hasn't
seen it yet now it's more critical than ever
yeah the this if rayne doesn't play 95 here i
think he's probably gonna lose okay he does but
he's had two moments had to find 95 and he found
him both times but again two minutes on the clock
yeah i mean i think for rain this is this is
really hard to play because the bishop on b2 is
bad black has the obvious lever with f6 to remove
that knight from e5 um and the queen and bishop
also are on c7 and d6 which are lined up very
neatly here yeah i want to see if sardis finds
f6 here which is a very good yeah f6 or even c3
first are both really good but i think f6 is just
kind of you know yeah i don't i don't
want to say obvious but when you just
move the knight it's got to be on his on his
agenda and indeed sardosh finds it this guy
this guy has just gotten so good over this last
month and he's playing this blitz game like a boss
yeah it's it's it's really weird it's like when
sardo she doesn't have time to think when he does
his like mind like start to you know mess with
his confidence he just plays free-flowing chess
he plays a lot better and i think that's
actually true a lot of people the last
time they had to think and start like being
insecure and worrying about this or that the
the better they play when they just can't
think it's just like they just move you
just play the game you don't let your brain
like disturb you and and mess up everything
well now reign is really getting down on
the clock and this is probably going to be
a story not not even just because of the clock
but he's also much worse on the board so it
would take a blunder by sardosh probably to give
rain chances yeah c3 here is very strong i think
d3 and knight g5 but oh
knight d5 oh no he blundered
does reigns see it knight is getting low
on time one minute on the clock found it
oh this is his last chance it's
gonna come down to the wire
but now king oh my god
all
now that was brutal what wow you don't
have finishes like that hey caro king f1
right after getting a after being worse all game
he gets his first chance with knight takes d5
is probably winning if he finds king h1
but instead blunders checkmate in one move
wow that's insane yeah that's crazy because
like you're right rain was worse the whole game
and i think he had enough time that he probably
would have won the game if he went king h1
he was still over a minute and everything
collapses the knight is weak the bishop
is weak all of black's pieces are completely
discombobulated nothing is coordinating at all
um so i think rain would have won if he won king
h1 but he goes to f1 and blunders the the amazing
92 checkmate and wow what a finish for sardosh
wow and it was a storybook finish for the french
streamer who showed up worked hard went full
hafu if we're talking uh pogchamps meme lore as
far as what she did in pogchamps too but sardosh
puts together an event for the ages hicaro and
comes all the way to the final to take pogchamps
three and the belt the belt by grip6 home exactly
oh my god we're gonna have interviews with both
these guys what a wild finish to this amazing two
weeks don't go anywhere everyone sardocian rayne
wilson join me and hikaru and we'll be right back
amazing two weeks don't go anywhere everyone
sardosh and rayne wilson join me in hikaru
and we'll be right back what a clutch game
this has been go anywhere what about oh it's
i'm just gonna mute this because i'm listening to
myself hello everybody what the game this has been
southern death tiebreaker sudden death blitz
game and this final moment it happened so quick
so let's just slow-mo let's slow-mo why this
is so big first of all stardust blundered he
blunders it after queen c7 the spawn is hanging
rain finds it with one minute on the clock so
now the queen is hanging the knight is
hanging white is doing very well here
sargeras gives a check to mess things up and he
did mess things up really badly for rain because
rain has two squares for the king two squares one
is winning the other is losing chess can be very
cruel sometimes if he had moved the king to the
corner the screen is still hanging the knight is
still hanging and this bishop could get trapped
too so basically black is in a lost position
he instead unfortunately instinctively goes the
other way and then steps into this night fork
but more than the queen that's gonna be gone it's
checkmate what a beautiful checkmate spectacular
position the knight delivering check made the
bishop taking away the g1 square the rook is
guarding the entire e5 the king has nowhere
to go this was the end of the tiebreaker
sardoche taking home the victory pogchamp three
winner i think even even if reign had chosen
this square to be fair with the time situation
having only one minute left on the clock with no
increment this would have been still quite a
difficult job to win sardoche had three minutes
versus one so i think even if reign haven't
made that blunder that final blunder king f1
yes white's position is winning but would he
have had the time to actually win him because
sardos would have kept playing obviously and
he has been playing really fast this blitz game
so i think even though objectively this position
is winning and white should be winning material
right now in this game for instance if queen to d6
you can take this knight on e4 because your knight
is safe because now look at this bing bang boom
the queen is gone this is one of the many tactical
patterns here this position is crazy sharp
but it suddenly would have been falling apart
from black's perspective you cannot touch this
knight if you take the rook the queen is now
guarding the knight and again this bishop is safe
on h2 either because white could be threatening to
block it to try to trap it on h2 would have been
crazy right but instead we have this checkmate
what a match what a match reign winning the first
rapid game that sardosh with a must win in the
second game and overall the clutch win in the
final blitz game i can't wait for the interview
it's still us though so i'm not gonna go back
to the official coverage because it's still up
my name is anna if you haven't met me i've been
one of the coaches for pogchamps as well i've been
working with the girl squad thank you so much
bottom for for the diamond membership i really
appreciate you're using my creator code i was
just summing up that if you guys haven't seen me
i have been one of the coaches for park gyms
i haven't worked with star dosh or rain but i
have worked with the ladies i've been i've been
the coach of the girl squad if we take a look at
the entire field these beautiful pictures i've
been working with pokemane with michelle carrey
with nico and with code miko the four female
participants and the honorary member of the girl
squad rubios i've had five students in the field
and i'm so proud of each and every one of them
for their own personal journeys their own personal
growth some of them had experience prior like nico
who was one of the first to play chess on twitch
before it was cool to play chess she already
was streaming chess on her channel while others
have only recently picked up chess thanks to the
queen's gambit too thanks to the game of xqc the
six move checkmate that mr beast was referencing
speaking of which let me let me go to the clips
and show you there's so many cool clips from
this event if you don't know how to find absolute
treasure you go to chess.com you click on videos
and then you go down to the clips part popular
clips do you remember this one for instance you
remember this moment i saw that clip on youtube
where you checkmated xhqc or whatever um second
one because i saw that clip on youtube where you
checkmated xhqc or whatever um yeah we don't even
remember his name it was so brutal but uh and so
now just you can relive some of the most hilarious
and we are back with rain wilson and sardosh who
gave us perhaps the most epic and wild ending
you could ask for in an overtime tiebreaker a
surprise checkmate but before we get into that
good news for you both community rally got us
over fifty thousand dollars so matched with a
hundred thousand by chess.com we have a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars going to charity and
a lot of it was driven on this last day so amazing
amazing stuff thank you guys and uh i don't know
where to begin with this sardosh let's dive into
the chess here because as you said off the camera
before we were joined you didn't even know that
knight d2 was made until you had played it right
i knew i would get a mate in three or four move
bringing my rook and getting the queen if you
will take my my queen i will i will get a lead of
course right when he moves the king on the on the
right i knew it was basically over but when i saw
the mate i felt like what did this just surrender
and it was it's much mates but i don't i don't
think it's like because my my whole point was
to pin that night to actually get behind and
it's that way that was my edition start and they
that backpost knight was supposed
to do something at some point and
he delivers the checkmate so i don't know man
this is crazy it's amazing congratulations rayne
we know that you said the sicilian was tough
but you had actually come you had fought all the
way back from a tough position we know you were
getting down on the clock but the moment knight 65
happened and then shakikara were like oh my god if
rain plays king h1 he might go on to win this game
because the queen's under attack the knights under
attack and the bishop and it all happens so fast
here so take us through your final moments there
obviously it was a shocking end here with king f1
yeah um and that's what time pressure will do
to you i had one minute he had three uh i didn't
think he had mate in two or three moves i thought
that i could i didn't really mind his bishop being
down there and i think i had enough firepower to
kind of clog up the middle and i had some threats
on him but so i just didn't take that beat to kind
of go where should i move my king but he you know
before we get into that just hats off chapeau's
off to sardoche and uh just great play all around
and and the better the better player won today
and uh he he just played great and um um but
yeah i just i get in trouble against the sicilian
and that's just something i'm going to have to
study i uh maybe get a better chess coach for it
i need a better chess coach carl are you available
yeah you know i was gonna say one of the things
um that was very difficult was sort of your setup
you played with this bishop to b2 is that a lot
of the positional play revolves around pushing
this pawn to d4 later on and then opening up
the diagonal for your bishop from b2 to h8 if
they if your opponent knows how to respond um in
the opening so it just seems like a very tricky
kind of opening setup to play if you're not
familiar with all the advanced opening ideas
if if i will play my initial setup i will lose
to this uh chunketto but right before the game
starts we analyzed only one one response
to selenium that was this opening because
the french staff is just too good at spying you
so they found the exact opening i needed to play
to actually be comfortable and once again shout
out to kevin body just an insane stuff i mean
that was a team win actually and i'm so proud
well well guys obviously we could talk about the
chess for a long time but the truth is you both
just played an incredible event and it came
down to literally overtime overtime chess to
decide a winner um last question for you both
i'll start with you rayne just give us your
20 seconds we know we know you played the event
and a big part of it was the opportunity for
charity which was awesome where the community
got us today but tell us more just about
you know how much you enjoyed playing the event
your your you know how much you love chess
and you know how was this experience playing in
pogchamps event sucked chess sucks france sucks
no man uh this is a lot of fun man it was listen
i'm an old i'm an old dude and i was for a little
while on the high school chess team it wasn't
very good um but to get to dive in and re-examine
the game in a fresh way was a lot of fun and
i'm really excited for the money that we made
uh for our non-profit sardosh if you want to
donate any of your winnings over to our charity
you're welcome my friend um and played some great
players along the way had a great experience
and um thrilled to be a part of it and
just big congratulations to sardosh on his
victory thanks a lot sardosh uh same question
to you just tell us your final thoughts on
playing in pogchamps and uh and where where you're
going from here with your with your chess career
um first of all out of all my esport career i
played some great league of legends tournaments i
played some great twitch rewards on many games but
out of everything that was the win i was the most
happy with like i i will actually fade out when
i when when this game is it was too much to under
i never felt something like this this this it has
been like two months i'm literally discovering the
game and getting obsessed with it and i play
like maybe 12 hours a day for like two months
so i'm i'm doing for four hours of puzzle you
can make it like it i i went to 2100 and like i
play six hours again every day just sometimes
never get out of my bed and paying my phone
uh that was something i really was focused on so
i'm so proud i want it and i know i will chill
a bit i will i will focus on another thing i will
pay you a bit of focus league and stuff like this
but i will never forget chess and play it's until
i get at least two thousand or sometimes some
i mean who can say i eat to the level some some
day in my life i think that will be a really good
life goal and i will definitely
and for it at some point here
and play on the board by the way would be awesome
yeah i don't think i've ever done anything for 12
hours a day so that's pretty incredible and you
earned it man um nicaragua any final thoughts
before our for our are guys here i i mean i
just think it was it was a great match you both
played well and for for sardosh i mean to see
the hours you put in to see it all pay off at the
end um it's just it's phenomenal i'm really really
happy for you i think out of all the pogchamps
winners um you were the one who showed the most
emotion you definitely felt the most pressure
when you were losing games we saw we saw how
much it affected you how how much it hurt and then
to come back and win at the end um and so just to
see the emotion the passion you had for chess it
was incredible and so very well deserved victory
well thank you guys both so much and again
thank you to the community who came through
in the clutch and got us over that 150 000
raised marker and the two largest percentages
going to reign in sardoshes uh
charities respectively but remember
all of the participants get a percentage to the
charities that they chose which is incredible so
guys what a wild ride thank you so much for doing
this congratulations to you both congrats sardoche
and uh maybe a future pogchamps and
we'll see you then bye yeah thanks guys
all right man well that was wild and uh what
a what a pog champs way to end it with a 92
surprise checkmate on the board a car yeah it was
i mean it was a great finish it sort of that game
swung back and forth the whole match swung back
and forth i think you know when i look at all the
pog champs this one had the most twists and turns
had the most competitive games and i'm just all
around it was a great event and really as i said
before to see sargo i should see the emotion see
how much time he put in and just to see the way
um the way that he took it so seriously and then
to come through win that second game then win
the tiebreaker i was just really really special
yeah he came through remember every i mean anyone
just who did i doubt they did but um i bet you've
been here the whole time but remember sardochi did
that in comeback fashion he had to win game two
to send it to overtime and then come through in
those super critical moments of that final blitz
game so sardosh that the hard work paid off and an
incredible and deserving podchamps champion there
hikaru speaking of incredible and deserving
you're getting a deserved raid you worked
hard today you're about to go stream on your
channel so go to twitch.tv slash gm hikaru
um man yeah it's i mean i'm i'll definitely be
talking about the event as well but i just think
in general the whole thing was was amazing and it
was really fun to watch i think one of the things
is you don't want to feel like there's a runaway
winner it's guaranteed someone's going to win
and it felt like anybody could have won felt
like benji he could have won in the champions
championship bracket um came a little bit short
against rain but i felt like reign also could
have probably won this let's not forget ludwig
who lost in overtime to sardo he always went all
the way exactly right so yeah it was just it was
a great it was a great great event and um i think
all the players uh they deserve a lot of credit
i feel like they put in a lot of work and and and
um and it's just it was a fun event really really
good probably out of all three was definitely my
favorite yeah no and it uh certainly reached uh
the records the records in terms of viewership
and and uh engagement that say that it was a lot
of other people's favorite too and so a huge thank
you to the community and uh everyone who tuned in
not just obviously for the charity but just seeing
where chess is going and huge thank you all of
our sponsors again gaia key cyberpowerpc grip6 who
made the belt apparently we don't ship to france
at chess.com so i'm just going to keep it that's
that's cool yeah good one good one danny i'm
pretty sure on the next next flight out of paris
they're gonna be a lot a lot of people who will be
coming forward the french faithful came through in
the uh in the main chat as well and we know that
sardoche had a massive audience behind him so
all right well um sometimes we don't want these
things to end but we got to close so again huge
thank you to the team all of our moderators who
work super hard uh keeping everyone just having a
good time and all the communities feeling feeling
loved and positive to the staff our producers are
our our team working hard behind all the all the
scenes that you don't even know exists um and uh
all the all the hard work that goes into making
sure that things don't go wrong and the amazing
thing that was presented here the commentators
pod champs we gotta think the coaches in caru
all the coaches that work super hard there's
a lot of time that goes in with the streamers
to help to help them get here and kevin bourdee
who already sent a message to me on slack i'm not
going to read it until i'm off air i don't know
what he said but congrats kevin of course with
the guy that you worked super hard with winning
the whole event and um and hikaru and everyone
who helps make pogchamps possible thank you let's
let's sign off and until pogchamps 4 i'll see you
then man absolutely it's great it's a pleasure
danny thank you so much bye everyone see you guys
come on
there's
rip
it's
camera
so
three two one